THIS JOINT HEARING OF A
ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW COMMITTEE
AND BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE SIX TO
ORDER.
AFTER.
AT TODAY'S HEARING WILL FOCUS ON
THE SCALP THE STATE STATE COUNTY
IN BUDGET CASH MANAGEMENT AND
PROCUREMENT SYSTEM.
CHAIR TANG AND AND OTHER MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US OF FOR
THE SESSION PARTICULARLY KNOW
THIS IS SUCH A BUSY TIME FOR
THOSE OF YOU.
WHO ARE ON BUDGETS OF SEX?
AB.
SU BEGINNING IN TWO THOUSAND
FIVE FISCALE IS ONE OF THE
STATE'S LARGEST EVER TECHNOLOGY
PROJECTS BEFORE I CAME TO
SACRAMENTO IS THE LEGISLATURE AS
A LEGISLATOR I'D SEEN REPORTS
ABOUT THIS GAL AND THEY WERE
CONCERNING.
THE FOURTEEN YEAR PROJECT THE
STATE SPENT ALMOST A BILLION
DOLLARS ON IT.
YET THERE CONTINUE BE PERSISTENT
DELAYS AND IMPLEMENTATION ISSUES
SO.
AS BUT THE TAXPAYER NOW THE
CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY IS
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMITTEE I'M
LOOKING FORWARD.
TO DIGGING IN I AND MANY MORE
ABOUT THIS PROJECT TODAY I LOOK
FORWARD TO TODAY'S DISCUSSION.
I'VE GOT THREE PRIMARY GOALS FOR
THIS HEARING NUMBER ONE TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE ON TRACK TO
DELIVER THE PROJECT.
I IN ITS LATEST RISK OF BEING
NUMBER TWO TO INSURE THAT WE ARE
ABLE TO ACCURATELY PRODUCE THE
STATE'S CRITICAL FINANCIAL
REPORTS.
AND NUMBER THREE ENSURE THAT
WE'RE NOT BACK HERE A YEAR FROM
NOW HAVE IN THE SAME
CONVERSATION.
I'M AS YOU GO THROUGH THE
CONVERSATION I'D LIKE TO
UNDERSTAND THE PROJECT STATUS SO
YOUR RELATIVE TO REGIONAL SCOPE
WHAT'S BEEN DELIVERED BUT THAT
ISSUES
WHAT'S THE PLAN TO ADDRESS THIS
I'M AND AS YOU UPDATE ASK IF YOU
CAN PLEASE ADDRESS THE SPECIFIC
ISSUES THAT BEEN RAISED IN.
THE AUDITOR'S AUGUST TWENTY
EIGHTEEN FIVE REPORT AND THEN
THE FOLLOW UP LETTER IN JANUARY
OF TWENTY NINETEEN AS WELL AS
THE MARCH.
TWENTY NINETEEN DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY REPORT AND THE MARCH
TWENTY NINETEEN LETTER FROM THE
CONTROLLER THAT WOULD BE
INCREDIBLY HELPFUL.
I'M.
CHARGING WOULD YOU LIKE TO MAKE
AN OPENING STATEMENT.
SURE JUST VERY QUICKLY HEY THANK
YOU AS A MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS TO
REALLY -- WORK WITH US TO CALL
THIS HEARING -- FIST CALLISON
EXTRAORDINARILY IMPORTANT
PROJECT -- ACTUALLY FROM THE
FROM THE BUDGET POINT OF VIEW
IT'S ACTUALLY.
HE HELPED IMPROVE OUR WORK
ALTHOUGH IT'S NOT.
COMPLETELY DONE -- IF WE REALLY
LOOK FORWARD TO THE PROJECT
BEING COMPLETED WE THINK IT'S A
VERY CRITICAL CRITICAL PROJECTS
NOT JUST FOR OUR BUDGETING
PROSOPIS REALLY FOR THE ENTIRE
STATE IN THE IDEA OF BEING ABLE --
TO WORK THROUGH ALL THESE
DIFFERENT LEGACY SYSTEMS --
START WITH A NEW SYSTEM ACTUALLY
HAPPENED ONCE SYSTEM WHERE WE
ARE ALL INTEGRATED WOULD BE
QUITE AN AMAZING FEAT FOR THE
STATE SO.
AGAIN.
REALLY EXCITED TO HEAR ABOUT ALL
THE WORK THAT IS BEING DONE AND
ALSO VERY INTERESTED TO HEAR.
WHAT ELSE YOU NEED TO DO TO GET
THE PROJECT COMPLETED THANK YOU?
WHAT ANYONE ELSE LIKE TO MAKE A
OPENING STATEMENT?
OKAY.
I'M WITH THAT WE WILL GET
STARTED SO I'M LIKE TO CALL
FISCAL DIRECTOR MERION GINNY
THERE TO JOIN US PLEASE.
WELCOME THANKS FOR BEING HERE
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THIS [inaudible]
SOMEONE [inaudible]
RANGED.
GOOD MORNING I THANK YOU FOR
HAVING US HERE TODAY -- MY NAME
IS MERRIAM BARCELONA ENGINE YOU
KNOW AND I AM THE DIRECTOR OF
THE FINANCIAL INFORMATION SYSTEM
FOR CALIFORNIA.
AND I'M NOT SURE HE WANTED
INTRODUCTIONS AROUND THE REST OF
THE TABLE OR YES THAT WOULD BE
GREAT GOOD MORNING RICHARD GILL
AND DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
GOOD MORNING GEORGE LE LET'S
CHIEF OPERATING OFFICER STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE.
FRANCISCO LANA WHETHER
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY AND BRIAN
METZGER WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE.
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU FOR
THE INTRODUCTION AS WELL.
AS ALL OF YOU ARE AWARENESS AS
THE CHAIR WOMAN HAS STATED --
THAT FITS GALA IS ONE OF THE
LARGEST I. T. UNDERTAKINGS THAT
THE STATE HAS.
EVER TAKEN AND WE HAVE BEEN YOU
KNOW THE THE ORIGINAL FSR WENT
OUT IN TWO THOUSAND AND FOUR
WHEN WE STARTED AS JUST A
REPLACEMENT OF THE BUDGETING
SYSTEM.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND SIX WITH AN
EXPANDED TO INCLUDE THE
REPLACEMENT OF LEGACY SYSTEMS
THAT WORK THE CONTROLLERS THE
TREASURER'S THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES.
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE A
SYSTEMS SO AS THE PROJECT YOU
KNOW EXPANDED SO DID SCOPE -- AS
WELL AS AS COSTS AND IT HAS
FLUCTUATED OVER THE YEARS AS
THAT SCOPE CONTINUE TO CHANGE
AND I JUST AS WE GOT MORE INTO
THE INTO THE PROJECT.
WE HIRED OUR SYSTEM INTEGRATOR
IN TWENTY TWELVE AND SO THAT IS
THE OFFICIAL.
BOOTS ON THE GROUND STARTING OF
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
PROJECT.
AND SINCE THEN I AM HAPPY TO SAY
THAT WE HAVE FULLY DEPLOYED THE
BUDGETING SOLUTION FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
THE BUDGET THAT WAS PRESENTED TO
YOU BY THE GOVERNOR THIS YEAR
WAS PRODUCED AS HAS EVERY BUDGET
SINCE.
TWENTY SIXTEEN THROUGH THE
INFORMATION IN THE HYPERION
SYSTEM SO THE DEPARTMENT'S INPUT
AT THE INFORMATION DIRECTLY INTO
THE SYSTEM.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DID
BACK AND FORTH WITH THE
DEPARTMENTS IN THE SYSTEM AND
ULTIMATELY PUT TOGETHER A A
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
WHAT IS EVEN MORE IMPORTANT
SENSE THE -- ON SINCE THE
RELEASE OF THE FISCAL SYSTEM
FROM THE BUDGETING PERSPECTIVE.
IS THAT THE ENACTED BUDGET NOW
IT HAS THE SAME LEVEL OF DETAIL
AS THE PROPOSED BUDGET.
SO THAT PROPOSED BUDGET AS WE
ALL KNOW IS THAT INITIAL POLICY
STATEMENT FROM THE GOVERNOR.
BUT IT'S ONLY AFTER THE
LEGISLATURE HAS DONE ITS WORK
ALLEN'S THE GOVERNOR HAS
ULTIMATELY SIGNED AND AND DONE
ANY LINE ITEM ADJUSTMENTS TO IT.
THAT IT IS THE THE LAW OF THE
LAND THAT LEVEL OF DETAIL HAD
NEVER BEEN AVAILABLE TO ADD THE
LEGISLATURE OR TO THE PUBLIC IN
AN EASY TO USE FASHION SO WE'RE
REALLY PROUD OF THAT --
ACHIEVEMENT.
IN ADDITION TO THE BUDGETARY
EXPENDITURES THAT ARE IN THE
SYSTEM AND WITH THE DEPARTMENTS
THAT WE HAVE IN THE SYSTEM
HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO
DEPARTMENTS.
WE HAVE ABOUT DOING ACCOUNTING
WE HAVE A THREE HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLARS WORTH OF BUDGETARY
EXPENDITURES THAT RUN FOR OUR
SYSTEM TODAY.
WE HAVE -- THAT THE BANKING
TRANSACTIONS ARE FULLY DEPLOYED
SO THE CASH MANAGEMENT FUNCTION
FROM THE TREASURER'S PERSPECTIVE --
IS DEPLOYED AND THEY MANAGE TO
TRILLION DOLLARS OF BANKING
TRANSACTIONS A YEAR NOW
UTILIZING THE FISCAL SYSTEM.
AND THAT IS WITH -- EIGHT LARGE
BANKS AND ALL OF THE INTERNAL.
BORROWING AND AND FINANCIAL
TRANSACTIONS CASH TRANSACTIONS
THAT HAPPENED IN THE SYSTEM.
LIKE I SAID THERE'S A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY TWO DEPARTMENTS AND
THAT TRANSLATES INTO IN THE
ACCOUNTING PIECE WHICH IS ALSO
DEPLOYED THE DEPARTMENTAL
ACCOUNTING PEACE HAS BEEN
DEPLOYED TO THESE DEPARTMENTS.
IT REPRESENTS THAT WE HAVE
EIGHTEEN I'M CLOSER ACTUALLY.
TO TWENTY THOUSAND END USERS
UTILIZING THE SYSTEM TODAY.
THAT REPRESENTS ABOUT 8% OF THE
TOTAL STATE EMPLOYEE WORK FORCE.
SO NOT ONLY IS FISCALE ONE OF
THE LARGEST I. T. UNDERTAKINGS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
BUT WE HAVE FUNDAMENTALLY
CHANGED THE WAY THAT CALIFORNIA
DOES BUSINESS AND FUNDAMENTALLY
CHANGE THE WAY EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
END USERS DO THEIR DAY TO DAY
WORK.
SO -- IN THE OTHER SORRY THE
OTHER PIECE OF FUNCTIONALITY
THAT HAS ALREADY BEEN FULLY
DEPLOYED IN CAME OUT IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN OF COURSE.
IS THE PROCUREMENT PIECE SO WE
RETIRED THE LEGACY BID SYNC
SYSTEM THAT CONTRACTORS UTILIZED --
TO TO SELL GOODS AND SERVICES TO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND WE
NOW UTILIZE -- CALLIE PROCURE
WHICH IS A SYSTEM RUN OUT WITH.
ON TOP OF THAT THE PEOPLE SOFT
SYSTEM WE HAVE NINETY SEVEN
THOUSAND VENDORS THAT SELL.
GOODS AND SERVICES TO THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
THROUGH THE DEPLOYMENT OF CALLIE
PROCURE WE WERE ABLE TO WE THIS
IS RIGHT AWAY MY MY PARTNER SAID
TGS IN THIS CASE WAS ABLE TO
CERTIFY SMALL BUSINESSES -- SB
DVD SO DISABLE BUSINESS VETERAN
ENTERPRISES UTILIZING THE SYSTEM
SO THAT.
IS AN EASE OF ARM AND BIGGER
ACCESS POINT FOR THE SMALLER.
COMPANIES AND SO THAT AGAIN IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE INCREDIBLY --
PROUD OF D. WITH RESPECT -- TO
FUNCTIONALITY THAT WE'VE NEVER
HAD BEFORE -- WE'VE HAD THE
ABILITY SENSE THE SYSTEM HAS
BEEN PUT IN PLACE. TO ENFORCE
THE UNDERLYING RULES AND
REGULATIONS THAT EXIST IN THE
STATE WITH RESPECT TO ACCOUNTING
BUDGETING AND AND OTHER
FINANCIAL MANAGEMENT.
SO THESE SYSTEM THAT DEPARTMENTS
OPERATED IT AND YOU'RE WERE
REQUIRED UNDER THE STATE
ADMINISTRATIVE MANUAL OR OTHER
REGULATION TO DO CERTAIN THINGS.
BY COMBINING ALL OF THE SYSTEMS
INTO A SINGLE INTEGRATED
SOLUTION.
THE DEPARTMENTS AT THE COMPUTER
IS THAT CHECK FOR THE CONTROL
AGENCIES SO BEFORE YOU CAN.
MAKE AN EXPENDITURE OUT OF THE
FISCAL SYSTEM.
THE SYSTEM TAX DO YOU HAVE
APPROPRIATIONS AUTHORITY.
YOU'RE ALWAYS SUPPOSED TO SPEND
ONLY IF YOU HAVE A PREPARATION
PRETTY BUT THE THE BUT THE
COMPUTER IS NOT FORGIVING.
THEN WHEN YOU GO TO ACTUALLY
MAKE AN EXPENDITURE DO YOU HAVE
CASH IN THAT ACCOUNT.
AT THIS MOMENT WHEN THE MONEY
NEEDS TO BE THERE AGAIN THOSE
ARE THINGS THAT ARE IN THE
SYSTEM.
SOME OF THE STRUGGLES THAT --
WE'VE HAD. FOR SOME OF THE
DEPARTMENTS.
OUR OUR INTO THAT FACT THAT SOME
OF THESE RESPONSIBILITIES THAT
THEY NEEDED TO BE DOING.
ARE NOW ALL HAPPENING IN REAL
TIME IN IN THIS SINGLE SYSTEM SO
YOU MIGHT HAVE HAD -- I DID A
DAY DELAY BETWEEN WHEN YOU
YOU'RE RIGHT YOUR CHECK TO WHEN
IT GETS DEPOSITED -- OR CASH IT
AND THAT'S NOT THE CASE SO MUCH
AND AND NOT FISCAL TODAY SO IT'S
MORE REAL TIME AND THEREFORE.
AS THERE IS THAT UP FRONT WORK
AND ACCOUNTABILITY THAT IS
HAPPENING.
I 98% OF ALL OF THE
FUNCTIONALITY THAT WE SET OUT TO
BUILD.
HAS BEEN BUILT.
THE REMAINING FUNCTIONALITY
WRITTEN REMAINS AROUND TO THE
CASH BOOK OF RECORDS SO THE
LEGACY -- SYSTEM AT THE AT THE
STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE WHICH
DOES THE CASH ACCOUNTING FOR THE
STATE.
NEEDS TO BE HAVE REPLICATED
ALLEN TO PUT INTO A FIST CAL AND
THAT IS WHAT WE WILL BE DOING IN
THIS NEXT YEAR.
WE DIVIDED IT THE INTEGRATED WE
DIVIDED THE ASIO RELEASE IN. TWO
FIVE MAJOR MILESTONES.
AND THIS WAS AFTER SEVERAL YEARS
OF US.
TRYING TO DO TO FIGURE OUT THE
BEST WAY TO BRING ON ALL OF THE
FUNCTIONALITY THE COMPTROLLER'S
WE HAD MANY MEETINGS ALONG THE
WAY AND ULTIMATELY THE FOUR
PARTNERS DECIDED THAT.
INSTEAD OF DOING A YOU KNOW
BANDAID RIPOFF THE BAND AID
APPROACH AND CUTTING OVER THE
BOOK OF RECORD IN ALL OF THEIR
OTHER FUNCTIONALITY ALL ONCE.
WE DEVELOP SOMETHING CALLED THE
INTEGRATED SOLUTION WHERE WE'RE
INTERFACING.
OUR SYSTEM WITH THE LEGACY
SYSTEM SO THAT WE CAN COMPARE --
IN ON A DAILY BASIS WHAT THOSE
NUMBERS ARE AND MAKING SURE THAT
EVERYTHING IS FULLY TESTED
BEFORE WE START TURNING OFF THE
LEGACY SYSTEM FUNCTIONALITY AT
THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE.
SO AGAIN THE ONLY PIECES THAT
ARE LEFT TO DEPLOY AND THAT
REALLY ARE AROUND THE CASH
MANAGEMENT.
WE HAVE WE ARE QUITE A WAYS DOWN
IN THE BUILDING.
BUT BECAUSE AGAIN.
IT.
HAS A REQUIREMENT TO BE RELEASED
ON THE BEGINNING A FISCAL YEAR
TO HAVE TO GO JULY.
ONE I CAN'T DO IT IN THE FIRST
QUARTER THE SECOND QUARTER EVEN
THOUGH WE MIGHT BE READY TO
DEPLOY IT HAS TO COINCIDE WITH
THE WITH THE CALENDAR YEAR SO
THAT.
THAT PIECE OF WORK IS IS AGAIN --
WORKING VERY WELL WITH WITH THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE AND THEIR
THEIR STAFF IN MAKING SURE THAT.
IT IS BUILT BUT THEN IT IS ALSO
FULLY TESTED AND VALIDATED
BEFORE WE PUT IT INTO PRODUCTION
FOR THE REST OF THE STATE.
AND IN THE FINAL PIECE THAT IS
LEFT TO BUILD.
IS THE KAFFIR WHICH IS THE OKAY
I HAVE TO ALWAYS READ THE
COMPREHENSIVE ANNUAL FINANCIAL
REPORT FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND IT IS A KEY DOCUMENT THAT IS
UTILIZED BY.
BY THE RATING AGENCIES BUT ALSO
BY OTHER INVESTORS AND STATE
CALIFORNIA AND SO -- IT IS A KEY
AN IMPORTANT DOCUMENT TO US AND
WE WILL BE CONTINUING THAT BUILD
AND DEPLOYMENT AS WELL IN THIS
YEAR.
SO HAVING SAID THAT ABOUT THE
SYSTEM I WANT TO SHIFT A LITTLE
BIT TO THE ACTUAL USE OF THE
SYSTEM.
SO HOW ARE THE DEPARTMENTS THE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO
DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE IN THE
SYSTEM HOW ARE THEY THE FAIRING.
SO FIRST -- ONE OF THE THE
ISSUES THAT HAS COME UP IN THE
CASF A AS WELL AS THE I PO AS
WELL AS IN -- THE CONTROLLERS
LETTER WAS THAT.
THAT WOULD WE NEED TO NOT BRING
ON ANYMORE DEPARTMENTS UNTIL
WE'VE WE'VE KIND OF STATE LAST.
ONE HAPPY TO SAY THAT ALL OF THE
DEPARTMENTS ARE ON THAT WE HAD
INTENDED TO DO SO THAT IT WAS
KIND OF A TIMING ISSUE WHEN WHEN
WE GOT THAT LETTER WHEN WE WE
DEPLOYED ALL OF THE DEPARTMENTS.
THE REMAINING DEPARTMENTS ON
JULY.
ONE TWENTY NINETEEN NOW THIS
DEPLOYMENT EFFORT WAS VERY --
JULY ONE TWENTY EIGHTEEN SORRY
WE'RE NOT THERE YET -- IS THAT
THIS EFFORT WAS DIFFERENT THAN
SOME OF OUR OTHER ON BOARDING
EFFORTS IN THAT THIS REMAINING
SIXTY FOUR I DIDN'T HAVE ANOTHER
CO COURTED DEPARTMENTS. TO DO
THE CHANGE MANAGEMENT AND THE
TASKS THAT ARE INVOLVED IN
BRINGING THEM ON SO I WAS ABLE
TO TAKE MY STAFF IN BED THEM
WITH SOME OF THE LARGER
DEPARTMENTS THE MORE COMPLICATED
DEPARTMENTS.
AND WORK WITH THEM SO THAT THEY
COULD HAVE AN EASIER ON BOARDING
THAN WE'VE EXPERIENCED IN THE
PAST.
THIS HAS PAID DIVIDENDS IN THAT
MANY OF THE LARGER DEPARTMENTS
THAT WE MADE THAT INVESTMENT IN
UP FRONT.
HAS BEEN ABLE -- TO KEEP UP WITH
THEIR MINDS AND AT IS ARE
FURTHER ALONG IN IN BETTER SHAPE
THAN WHAT WE'VE SEEN AT THIS
POINT IN TIME FOR PREVIOUS
RELEASES.
NOW ONE DEPARTMENT THAT STICKS
OUT IN MY MIND IS CAL FIRE AND
AGAIN WHEN I SAY WE
INDIVIDUALIZED AND WE WERE ABLE
WE HAVE THE CAPACITY BECAUSE WE
WEREN'T WORKING ON BRINGING ON
THE NEXT CULL COURT.
WE WERE ABLE TO PROVIDE THEM
THERE AND PROJECT MANAGEMENT
TEAM AND KNOWING THAT JULY ONE
MIGHT BE THE ABSOLUTE BEST TIME
TO CUT OVER FOR FINANCIAL
RECORDS.
IT IS ONE OF THE ABSOLUTE WORST
TIMES FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA -- TO MOVE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION SO THEY'RE IN THE THE
HEAT OF THE FIRE SEASON -- AND
AND DOING THIS CHANGE MANAGEMENT
IN THE MIDDLE WHEN THEY NEED TO
BE ABLE TO PAY THEIR BILLS.
IT IT YOU KNOW WHEN THEY'RE
EXPEDITED FASHION AND NOT HAVE
THIS THIS CHANGE AND ROB THEM.
SO WE DID A CONVERSION WITH THEM
AND THEN IN JANUARY THEY STARTED
TRANSACTING IN THE SYSTEM.
SO WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO BRING
THEM.
ALONG WITH US WORKING WITH THEM
THEY'VE HAD AN INCREDIBLE
COMMITMENT AND I I JUST I DO
HAVE TO SING THE PRAISES OF OF
CAL FIRE.
BECAUSE IT WAS THIS MUTUAL
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW IMPORTANT
THEIR CORE FUNCTIONS WORK AND
WHAT WE NEEDED TO DO TO MAKE
SURE THEY WERE ABLE TO NOT MISS
A BEAT WHEN THEY CAME ON TO OUR
SYSTEM.
I'M HAPPY TO SAY THAT THEY ARE
ONE OF THE DEPARTMENTS THAT IS
CURRENT SO THEY HAVE CLOSED NINE
MONTHS OUT OF THE NINE MONTHS
WE'RE EXPECTED TO HAVE CLOSED AT
THIS POINT IN TIME -- AND I WILL
YOU KNOW IGNORE ALL AGE THAT
THEY'VE ONLY RECONCILED TO OF
THOSE MONTHS BUT AGAIN THAT
HAPPENS IT'S AN ACCOUNTING
ACTIVITY OUTSIDE OF THE FISCAL
SYSTEM.
THAT THEY DO -- ON THEIR OWN OR
WITH THE ASSISTANCE OF SAY THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
ADDITIONAL PAIN POINTS THAT THE
DEPARTMENTS HAVE HAD.
IS DETAILS.
SO INSTEAD OF DOING ON A HIGH
LEVEL HAS SINGLE CLAIM AUDIT FOR
UP -- FOR SINGLE CLAIM FOR A LOT
OF INVOICES THEY'RE HAVING TO DO
IT LINE ITEM.
SO EACH LINE OF AN INVOICE GETS
ENTERED INTO THE SYSTEM.
AND THE REASON THAT IS IS
BECAUSE THIS IS.
THE AMOUNT OF TRANSPARENCY THAT
WAS ONE OF THE KEY GOALS OF THE
FISCAL SYSTEM.
REQUIRES THAT -- THAT IN ORDER
FOR US TO BE ABLE TO KNOW HOW
MUCH WE'RE SPENDING ON ON ON
CRITICAL AREAS WE NEED TO HAVE
IT.
CAPTURED THAT WAY.
THE FLIP SIDE OF THAT COIN IS DO
WE COLLECT -- YOU KNOW DO WE
NEED TO KNOW THAT THE PRISONS
ARE BUYING.
GALA APPLES OR GRANNY SMITH
APPLES OR DO I NEED TO KNOW THAT
THEY'RE BUYING FOR IT.
AND SO THIS IS A POLICY
DISCUSSION THAT IS HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW BETWEEN THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
AND THEY'RE WORKING ON WHAT IS
THE RIGHT LEVEL OF DETAIL TO BE
CAPTURED.
AND SO THAT.
IS SOMETHING THAT I THINK IS YOU
KNOW MORE PERFECT FOR THAT THE
SECOND PANEL BUT THOSE ARE THE
TYPES OF ISSUES THAT ARE
DEFINITELY DRIVING ADDITIONAL
WORK. FOR THE DEPARTMENTS AND ON
THE FLIP SIDE THE ADDITIONAL
WORKON THE CONTROL AGENCY SIDE
IS THAT.
AGAIN WHEN WE WERE WE WOULD SEND
AND WE GET IT RIGHT BE
CONSIDERATE WE WOULD HAVE A SO
BASICALLY IF A CONSOLIDATED --
DEPOSIT NOW THE DEPOSITS FOR
EACH DEPARTMENT ARE EACH
TRANSACTION HAVE ITS OWN LINE
ITEM IN THERE SO WHERE'S THE
CONTROLLERS WORKLOAD WENT FROM
OKAY WE'VE GOT THIS DEPOSIT OF A
MILLION DOLLARS INTO THIS HIGH
LEVEL ACCOUNT.
BECAUSE AGAIN THE CONTROLLERS AT
A MUCH HIGHER LEVEL OF REPORTING
IN THE FISCAL SYSTEM WANTED THIS
MORE DETAILED LEVEL.
WE'RE NOW REQUIRING THEM TO COME
TO PUT THE INFORMATION IN A
DETAILED LEVEL THERE BY DRIVING
WORK -- EFFORT AT THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE AS OTHERS
THAT BACK LAW.
AND SO WE HAVE BEEN PARTNERING
WITH THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE TO LOOK AT THAT WORK FLOW
AND LOOK AT WAYS THAT WE CAN.
MEET THEIR NEEDS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE HITTING THE RIGHT
FUNDS AND THAT THEY HAVE THE
RIGHT LEVEL OF OVERSIGHT.
WITHOUT BEING AN UNDUE BURDEN ON
THE ADDITIONAL WORK THAT THEY
HAVE.
SO THOSE ARE SOME OF THE THE THE
ISSUES THAT WE HEAR ABOUT FROM
THE DEPARTMENTS -- THEN WE ALSO
HEAR SOME CONCERNS FROM.
FROM VENDORS.
SO THIS HAS BEEN SOMETHING THAT
WHEN I'VE I'VE BEEN ON THE
PROJECT FOR ABOUT FOUR YEARS NOW.
I WHEN I FIRST CAME ON WE HAD
JUST.
RELEASE WE HAD ABOUT THIRTY OR
FORTY DEPARTMENTS IN IN THAT
THIS IS NEVER THE SMALLER ONES
THEY WERE THE ONES THAT WERE
BOARD MEMBERS AND HAD -- USUALLY
OTHER DEPARTMENTS EITHER HELPING
THEM WITH THEIR BOOKS OR NOT.
BUT I WAS CALLED IN FRONT OF A
LEGISLATURE A COUPLE OF TIMES AS
WELL AS IN FRONT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE TO EXPLAIN --
CABLE.
I'VE GOT BOARD MEMBERS THAT ARE
GETTING PAID.
AND I BRING THIS EXAMPLE UP
BECAUSE I THINK THAT THIS IS A
SUCCESS OF FISCALE. ONE OF THE
REQUIREMENTS TO GET PAID FROM
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS THAT
YOU HAVE THE APPROPRIATE TAX
INFORMATION.
RECORDED WITH THE STATE SO WE
KNOW HOW.
TO ISSUE YOUR TEN NINETY NINE OR
YOUR W. TWO OR WHATEVER YOU THE
RIGHT TAX DOCUMENT IS.
SO WE CALL THAT IT'S YOU KNOW
IT'S A STANDARD TWO OH FOUR FORM.
WE FOUND THAT WHEN WE
IMPLEMENTED FISCALE.
THERE WERE A LOT OF VENDORS
INCLUDING MEMBERS THAT WERE PART
TIME MEMBERS ON BOARD CHECK OUT
PER DIEM THEY DIDN'T HAVE THESE
THIS INFORMATION ON FILE.
SO WHILE IT WAS A PAIN POINT FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS AT THE TIME.
IT WAS ABSOLUTELY THE RIGHT
THING FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THOSE HAVE ALL.
YOU KNOW THOSE ISSUES HAVE ALL
GONE AWAY AT THIS POINT THERE'S
YOU KNOW IT'S BECOME THE
EXPECTATION AND AND IT IS NOW
THE NORM.
NOW THERE ARE OTHER YOU KNOW
STRUGGLES THAT THAT VENDORS DO
HAVE -- DEPARTMENTS HAVING
GETTING SOME OF THE PAYMENTS OUT.
SOMETIMES IT IS WE'RE HITTING
THE WRONG ACCOUNTS AND AGAIN
THIS IS A LEARNING CURVE WE
FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE THE WAY
THEY'VE DONE THEIR JOBS.
AND SO WHAT WE ARE DOING WITH
SOME OF THE RESOURCES THAT WAS
PROVIDED TO US IN THIS THIS
BUDGET TO THANK YOU ALL VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF THAT.
IS THAT WE'RE BRINGING.
RESOURCES TO BEAR. TO THE
DEPARTMENTS TO HELP THEM WITH
THE CHANGE MANAGEMENT PIECE SO
THAT THEY ARE.
MORE ABLE TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES
BEFORE THE MISTAKES HAPPEN.
WE'RE ALSO UTILIZING RESOURCES.
TO ASSIST WITH THE RESOLUTION OF
OF MORE LEGACY KENNETH ERRORS OR
ISSUES THAT MAY HAVE COME IN AS
PART OF THEIR CONVERSIONS.
AND WE'RE ALSO UTILIZING THOSE
RESOURCES TO PROVIDE.
FASTER TICKET RESPONSE TIME IN
MY OWN SHOP SO AGAIN IF IF
THEY'VE GOT AN ISSUE WHAT WHAT
IS MY TURN AROUND TIME TO BE
ABLE TO GET THAT. TO GET THE
DEPARTMENTS BACK AND MOVING --
SO AS YOU CAN SEE A LOT OF THE
ISSUES AND THE STRUGGLES THAT
THE DEPARTMENTS ARE HAVING.
ARE NOT SO MUCH WITH THE I. T.
NOT THAT THE I. T. IS PERFECT
AND YOU KNOW THERE IS ANOTHER
ISSUE WHERE WE HAD.
TRANSACTION TAKING FORTY FIVE
SECONDS TO PROCESS AT THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE WE'VE
GOTTEN THAT DOWN TO SIX SECONDS
AND WE'RE CONTINUING TO LOOK AT
HOW DO WE IMPROVE THE SPEED OF
THE SYSTEM.
WE'RE LOOKING AT AGAIN WITH THE
RESOURCES PROVIDED PULLING OUT --
THE ANALYTICS PIECE IN THE
REPORTING PIECE OUT OF THE THE
MAIN SYSTEM THE FUNCTIONAL
SYSTEM AND PUTTING ANY WAS
SEPARATE INSTANT SO AGAIN THAT'S
NOT A LAG.
OR WHERE ON THE SYSTEM CAUSING --
DELAYS OR ANY HANG UPS ON ANY
OTHER SERVER SO.
WELL THERE AREN'T YOU KNOW LOTS
OF AYE HE PROBLEMS AT THIS POINT
YOU KNOW THE TICKETING DATA
SHOWS THAT WHEN I FIRST DEPLOYED.
WE HAD A SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER
SYSTEM NUMBER NUMBER SYSTEM
ISSUES AND WHAT HAS HAPPENED IS
THAT YOU KNOW THAT THE USER AS
THE USER NUMBERS HAVE GONE UP SO
HAVE THE HOW TO QUESTIONS.
SO THAT'S WHERE WE ARE FOCUSING --
A LOT OF OUR AT OUR OUR EFFORTS
TODAY -- SO.
AS THE PROJECT NEARS COMPLETION
AND AND WE REALLY HAVE FOCUSED
IN THE LAST YEAR ON SHIFTING TO
THAT.
DEPARTMENTAL SUPPORT WE'VE DONE
A COUPLE OF KEY THINGS.
WE INCREASED -- THE
PARTICIPATION AN INSTRUCTOR LED
TRAINING.
OUT AND WE'VE DONE THAT BOTH ON
SITE AT FISCALE WHICH WE CALL
USER SUPPORT LABS BUT WE'VE
AGAIN BEEN ABLE TO PUT MORE
RESOURCES IN THE DEPARTMENTS TO
ASSIST WITH THAT.
WE'VE HAD -- THE DEPARTMENT
STAFF TAKE THIRTY THREE THOUSAND
SELF GUIDED COURSES IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THAT NUMBER IS
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER THAN THE
PAST WE ARE LOOKING AT UPDATING
THE CURRICULUM AND KEEPING THAT
MODERN AS WELL.
AND SO AGAIN THIS IS THE
CONTINUAL RE FRESH THAT WE NEED
TO BE DOING AS WE DO
ENHANCEMENTS -- TO TO THE SYSTEM.
WE HAVE DEPLOYED SELF SERVICE
OPPORTUNITIES WHERE WE CAN'T SO
USERS ARE THEY BEING ABLE TO
COME IN INSTEAD OF HAVING TO
CALL AND ASK. FOR EITHER A
PASSWORD RESET OR TO HAVE
SOMEBODY NEW ON THEIR ACCOUNTING
STAFF ADDED WITH WITH ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES IN THE SYSTEM.
THEY CAN DO THAT ONLINE -- AND
IS EITHER ENTIRELY AUTOMATED OR
IT DOES REQUIRE THAT YOU KNOW A
HUMAN INTERVENTION IN OUR AND IF
CERTAIN FLAGS COME OFF -- WERE
ABLE TO ENFORCE THE SEPARATION
OF DUTIES THAT WAY THE
DEPARTMENTS ARE THEN NOTIFIED
SAYING OKAY WELL THIS PERSON
CANNOT BE BOTH AN APPROVER.
AS WELL AS A REQUEST -- AND THEN
THE DEPARTMENTS ARE ULTIMATELY
GIVEN THAT AUTHORITY TO SAY YES
BUT I ONLY HAVE TWO PEOPLE IN MY
COUNTY SHOP THEY HAVE TO AND SO
WERE WE ARE AT KNOWLEDGE CHIANG
THIS VIOLATION OF THE SEPARATION
OF DUTIES AND AS A BACK IT'S
RECORDED AS WELL.
SO THAT AGAIN.
THE DEPARTMENT'S ONLY DATED THE
DEPARTMENTS ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
THEIR ACCOUNTING IN THEIR BOOKS
AND THEIR UTILIZING OUR SYSTEM
TO DO IT SO THERE'S DEFINITELY
LINES AS TO WHAT I HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO DO AND WHAT REALLY
PROTECT REMAINS WITH.
THOSE DEPARTMENT DIRECTORS --
AND WE'RE ALSO REALLY FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN GAUGING THE
DEPARTMENTS ON THEIR NEEDS.
SO SINCE WE STARTED DEPLOYING
THIS IN TWENTY TWELVE WE HAVE
REALLY FOCUSED ON THE FLOOR
CONTROL AGENCIES AND WHAT ARE
THE REQUIREMENTS NEEDED TO MEET
THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL AND
STATUTORY RESPONSIBILITIES.
WE'VE ALWAYS HAD AN EYE TOWARDS
THE OTHER DEPARTMENTS HAVE TO BE
THESE USERS BUT THAT HAS NEVER
BEEN THE FOCUS.
SO I'M HAPPY TO SAY THAT IN
APRIL WE KICKED OFF -- WHAT WE
CALL IMAGINE FISCALE AND THESE
ARE DESIGN LED THINKING SESSIONS
THEY WERE THREE DAYS WHICH WE
INVITED ALL OF THE DEPARTMENTS
THEY AT? HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO
DEPARTMENTS WERE INVITED A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOR THIRTY I
THINK THIRTY SIX DEPARTMENTS AND
ULTIMATELY AFTER HUNDRED THIRTY
PARTICIPANTS Là WITH THIRTY SIX
DEPARTMENTS WERE WERE
PARTICIPATING.
OUT OF THAT WE LOOKED WE HAD A
WHOLE DAY DEDICATED TO WHAT ARE
YOU WORE.
CUSTOMER SERVICE NEEDS HOW CAN
THE FISCAL SYSTEM THE FISCAL
STAFF SUPPORT YOU BETTER IN
UTILIZING THE SYSTEM.
THEN WE HAD ANOTHER WHOLE DAY
DEDICATED TO TRAINING HOW CAN
THE FISCALE.
DEPARTMENTS AND PARTNER
DEPARTMENT IN PARTNERS BETTER
EQUIPPED SHIELD AND THEN FINALLY
THE LAST IT WAS ON THE SYSTEM
[inaudible]
WE HAVE.
YOU KNOW FROM THERE WE HAD
TWENTY TWO IDEAS SEVEN OF THEM
ARE BEING -- DEPLOYED AS WHOLE
CONCEPTS IN THE NEXT -- THIRTY
SIXTY NINETY DAYS AND THEN WE
HAVE ANOTHER HANDFUL THAT WERE
PORTIONS OF THOSE LARGER CONCEPT
SO AGAIN THAT IS THE BEGINNING
OF WHAT WE EXPECT TO BE DOING --
A COUPLE OF TIMES A YEAR WITH
THE DEPARTMENT'S FEEDING INTO MY
ENHANCEMENT PROGRAM WE DO
SEVERAL HUNDRED ENHANCEMENTS --
EVERY MONTH OR SO AND AND SO
IT'S AN EVERY QUARTER SO AND SO
WE NEED TO TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE FOCUSING IN ON THE RIGHT
THINGS -- ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WAS ASKED AS I WAS BRIEFING WITH
SOME OF YOU WAS HOW ARE WE
MEASURING OUR SUCCESS.
SO WITH THESE RESOURCES THAT
HAVE BEEN PROVIDED TO US.
THE THE GOAL IS TO MOVE -- TO
GET.
YOU KNOW 85% OF THE DEPARTMENTS
TO CLOSE ACTUAL -- BY THE END OF
NEXT YEAR AND THIS YEAR WE'RE
GOING TO BE VERY CLOSE TO THAT
AS WELL IS WHAT WE'RE
ANTICIPATING.
THE REST IS A IS WILL BE DOT
WILL BE CLOSED USING ESTIMATES
THAT AGAIN THE FOLLOWING
GUIDELINES ESTABLISHED BY.
THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE AS WELL AS
WITH INPUT FROM THE CSA SO IN
AGAIN THE SECOND PANEL COULD
SPEAK MORE TO ACCOUNTING THAN I
CAN BUT SO THESE ARE SO THAT'S
ONE OF THE GOALS THAT WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE ENOUGH KNOWLEDGE
TRANSFER HAPPENING IN THE
DEPARTMENTS.
THAT OVER THE NEXT TWO YEARS WE
WILL BE SUFFICIENTLY TRAINING
THE DEPARTMENT AT HOME ON THEIR
UNIQUE PROCESSES ON THEIR UNIQUE
SITUATIONS AND NEEDS.
HOW TO BE SUCCESSFUL UTILIZING
THE FISCAL SYSTEM?
WE WILL ALSO HAVE -- A GOAL OF
WE HAVE A GOAL TO HAVE ALL OF
OUR TICKETS.
AND BUT 90% OF OUR TICKETS ARE
CLOSED IN FIVE DAYS OR LESS
[inaudible]
SO.
AGAIN THESE ARE ISSUES THAT THAT.
ARE HOLDING DEPARTMENTS OP FROM
BEING ABLE TO DO THEIR WORK IN
THE SYSTEM AND WE NEED TO BE
MORE RESPONSIVE.
ON THAT WE RIGHT NOW ARE AT 71%
OF TICKETS ARE CLOSED IN FIVE
DAYS OR LESS.
AND ANOTHER -- EIGHTEEN SO IS
CLOSED AND JEFF EIGHTEEN BETWEEN
SIX AND FOURTEEN DAYS SO THOSE
ARE THE NUMBERS THAT WE ARE YOU
KNOW TARGETING THERE ARE ALWAYS
GOING TO BE SOME OF THOSE
TICKETS.
THAT ARE REALLY ENHANCEMENTS OF
SOME SORT OR OR ARE TRULY A BODY
THAT WE NEED TO WORK WITH --
ORACLE OR THE UNDERLYING.
PROVIDER ON SOME OF THOSE TWO TO
ADDRESS.
I'M SO S. P. R. EIGHT IS ALSO AN
OUTCOME OF THIS PAST YEAR'S WORK
AT THE RECOGNITION THAT.
WE WERE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
DEPLOY THE CASH COMPONENTS IN.
JULY OF THIS YEAR AND THAT IT
WOULD TAKE ANOTHER YEAR.
SO WE PUT FORWARD AT THE SAME
TIME AS WE HAD OUR REQUEST INTO
THE LEGISLATURE FOR ADDITIONAL
FUNDING.
WE HAVE A SPECIAL PROJECT REPORT
NUMBER EIGHT AT C. D. T. --
WE'VE GOT THAT TO THEM I THINK
LAST WEEK AND SO THEY HAVE ABOUT
TWO WEEKS THAT THEY WILL BE
LOOKING AT IT AND PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL FEEDBACK.
WE WERE ABLE TO WORK WITH THEM --
IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF IT AS WELL
AS WITH OUR FOR PARTNERS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE WERE ADDRESSING THE
ISSUES THAT WOULD IN FACT
CHANGES FROM AT RED STATUS BACK.
TO TO A GREEN OR AT AT THE VERY
LEAST A A YELLOW STATUS SO -- SO
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THEM ON
THAT IT HAS BEEN IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE BECAUSE
AGAIN THAT THE TESTING IN THE
ABILITY TO TO GET THE REMAINING
WORK DONE REALLY IS BETWEEN US
AND THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE.
WE HAVE AGREEMENT ON THIS S. P.
R. IN THIS PATH FORWARD TO GET
US TO DON BY JULY [inaudible]
ONE TWENTY TWENTY NOW.
FROM THERE WE WILL YOU KNOW THEY
WILL RUNTHAT THE KAFFIR IN
PARALLEL FOR ONE TO TWO YEARS
BEFORE TURNING OFF THEIR SYSTEM
BUT AGAIN THAT THOSE ARE.
YEAH THAT'S WHERE MY WORK KIND
OF STOPS AND THERE'S STARTS IF
YOU WILL -- SO WE GET A JUST IN
IN CLOSING.
THE THE RESOURCES THAT WERE
PROVIDED IN THE SPRING FINANCE
LADDER -- WE WILL BE COMPLETING
THE SCO FUNCTIONALITY AND EXACT
REQUEST THAT WE HAD BEFORE YOU
IT INCLUDED SIX MILLION DOLLARS
TO DO THAT -- WE PROVIDE
ENHANCEMENT SUPPORT FOR ALL OF
THAT THE CUSTOMERS WHICH WAS
ABOUT FIFTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS OVER THE THREE YEARS.
SO WE GET AND HOW MUCH CHANGE
MANAGEMENT HOW MUCH COMEY
INSTITUTIONALIZING DOCUMENT AND
MAKE SURE THAT THE KNOWLEDGE IS
THE KNOWLEDGE TRANSFER NOT ONLY
HAPPENING WITHIN FISCALE.
IT ALSO HAS TO HAPPEN AT THE
DEPARTMENTS RIGHT WILL CONTINUE
TO LOSE MY GREAT STAFF TO DO.
WILL BE IN THIS IS A VICIOUS
LOOP -- AND AND THE DOLLARS
REALLY DO REFLECT THAT THE SHIFT
IN THE FOCUS REALLY IS ABOUT.
THE CUSTOMER SUPPORT AND
CUSTOMER SERVICE.
BECAUSE WE ARE ARE CONFIDENT
THAT THAT THE SYSTEM IS IN IN
GOOD SHAPE.
WE ARE NOT.
BUILDING THE LEGACY SYSTEM OF
TOMORROW WE'RE BUILDING A
PLATFORM FOR THE FUTURE.
WE HAVE -- AS I HAD MENTIONED
EARLIER WE ARE DOING CONSTANT
ENHANCEMENTS WE HAVE AN
ENHANCEMENT PROCESS SO IN
ADDITION TO THE POINT THAT LAST
BIT OF FUNCTIONALITY.
WE'RE CONSTANTLY LOOKING TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE.
PROVIDING THE BEST SERVICE AND
THE BEST SYSTEM. FOR THE NEEDS
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA GREAT
WONDERFUL WELL THANK YOU BEFORE
WE HEAR FROM OUR OTHER PANELISTS.
I MEAN IT'S JUST A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS MAKE SURE THAT.
I UNDERSTAND CAN OUR STATUS SO.
HE BEGAN THE UPDATE BY SAYING
THE SYSTEM IS FULLY DEPLOYED.
IN THE AUDITOR'S REPORT IN
AUGUST OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND IN
THE AUDITOR'S LETTER OF JANUARY.
TWENTY NINETEEN THEY CALLED TO
ATTENTION KIND OF THIS
FUNDAMENTAL DISCONNECT ABOUT THE
DEFINITION OF DEPLOYED AND WHAT
THAT ACTUALLY MEANS SO NOT AS
OTHER SAID ACCORDING TO THE
PROJECT OFFICE.
IMPLEMENTED MEANS SYSTEM IS
READY TO USE AND THE ENTITY HAS
A STARTING POINT FOR RECORDING
TRANSACTIONS.
IMPLEMENTED DOES NOT MEAN THAT
ENTITIES HAVE TRANSITION FOR
LEGACY SYSTEMS TO PASCAL NOR
DOES IT MEAN THAT USERS WITH IN
THOSE ENTITIES ARE FULLY TRAINED
DOT TRANSACTION ARE CONDUCTING
THE STATE'S BUSINESS.
WITH BEST GAL SO I THINK WHEN I
HEAR FULLY DEPLOYED I HEAR
PEOPLE ARE ACTUALLY USING IT.
WHEN YOU SAY FULLY DEPLOYED?
WHAT DO YOU ACTUALLY MEAN SO AT
THIS POINT IN TIME?
I ONLY HAVE FIVE DEPARTMENTS
UTILIZING A LEGACY SYSTEM OKAY
SO FOUR OF THEM.
ARE USING THE CAL STAR SYSTEM.
TWO OF WHICH ARE DOING IT FOR A
FEDERAL REPORT.
THAT AGAIN THE ISSUE -- IS RIGHT
NOW OUTSIDE OF THE SYSTEMS
CONTROL AND IS WITH MY PARTNERS
WITH IT THE DEPARTMENT FINANCING
THE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE ON THE
REQUIREMENTS THAT NEED TO BE YOU
KNOW THEY'RE THEY'RE JUST MAKING
SHORTEN CLEARING THIS WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
SO AGAIN IT'S NOT PER SE A
SYSTEM ISSUE IT'S IT'S THAT
POLICY IN MAKING SURE THAT THAT
WE'RE GETTING THE RIGHT
INFORMATION SO THAT IT WAS WITH
A COUPLE OF THE DEPARTMENTS.
AND THEN THERE ARE TWO THAT ARE
DOING DO WILL TRANSACTING IN THE
SYSTEM -- AND WILL LIKELY CLOSE
IN THE CAL STARS SYSTEM AND THAT
WOULD BE THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD.
AND AGAIN WITH THE NATURE OF
WHAT THEY DO YOU -- IT WAS
DEEMED AGAIN BY THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCING THE PROJECT IT WAS IT
THAT WAS APPROPRIATE TO HAVE
THAT THAT ADDITIONAL SAFETY NET
FOR THEM -- AND THEN THAT SECOND
DEPARTMENT IS [inaudible]
DDS [inaudible]
DSS THANK.
I KNEW WHAT I HEAR WHISPERS FROM
BEHIND ME -- THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES IS IS THAT THE
SECOND DEPARTMENT THAT WILL BE
CLOSING UTILIZING A LEGACY
SYSTEM.
NOW THE OTHER DEPARTMENT THAT IS
UTILIZING A LEGACY SYSTEM THAT
WE THAT WE ARE AWARE OF IS --
THE EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT EDT AND THEY DO NOT
USE CAL STARS SO IT'S UNCLEAR TO
US HOW MUCH -- OF THE WORK WE DO
HAVE VISIBILITY INTO THEIR
LEGACY SYSTEM SO I CAN'T REALLY
DO A FAIR COMPARISON TO KNOW
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF THE WORK IS
HAPPENING IN FISCAL VERSES.
IN THEIR LEGACY BUT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THEY TOO
WILL BE CLOSING THEIR BOOKS THIS
YEAR IN THEIR LEGACY SYSTEM.
SO WE SAID THAT WAS DEPLOYED TO
ALL THE DEPARTMENTS WE HAD DONE
THEIR CONVERSIONS.
AND WE HAVE HAD THEM READY IN A
POSITION WHERE WHAT WAS THE NEXT
STEPS WITH A NEEDED -- TO
VALIDATE THE INFORMATION THAT
HAD BEEN CONVERTED.
DO ANY ADDITIONAL CONFIGURATIONS
THAT NEEDED TO BE DONE ON THE
POST GO LOCAL GO LIVE SIDE
BECAUSE EACH OTHER DEPARTMENTS
CAN DO THEIR OWN CONFIGURATIONS
FOR LABOR AND ALLOCATIONS AND
SOME OF THOSE THINGS.
AND IT ABSOLUTELY THERE WAS A
NUMBER OF DEPARTMENTS AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE THE CUTOVER
THAT WERE UTILIZING BOTH FISCALE
AND AND CAL STARS.
BUT THAT WAS TRUE WITH ALL OF
THE RELEASES IT IS THAT THAT.
COMFORT WITH WHAT YOU NOW IN IN
YOUR ABILITY TO TO PULL REPORTS
OUT IS YOU KNOW IN A TIMELY
FASHION.
WE CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENTS THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE -- AND YOU KNOW OTHERS
THAT ARE CREATING REPORTS IN THE
SYSTEM FOR THE DEPARTMENT THEY
WERE TAKING THEM FROM THERE.
YOU KNOW WHAT DID CAL STARS AND
YOU KNOW I WANTED TO RUN REPORT.
WELL FOR WHATEVER IT IS THAT IT
MEANS SOMETHING IN PLAIN
LANGUAGE.
I TO THEM IN THE IN IN THE
FISCAL SYSTEMS THAT CROSSWALK
HAS BEEN DON IN IS AVAILABLE ON
SOME KEY REPORTS FOR FOR
MOUNTAINEERING CLOSE.
AND THAT IS AVAILABLE ON THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCES WEBSITE AS
WELL AS LINKS FROM MY SIDE SO WE
ARE CONTINUING TO IDENTIFY THOSE
TYPES OF ISSUES AND ONE OF THE
HURDLES.
BETTER KEEPING DEPARTMENTS FROM
BEING AS FLOWING TO THE SYSTEM.
BUT VERY FEW DEPARTMENTS STILL
HAVE ACCESS BESIDES VIEWING
ACCESS TO THEIR CAL STARS DATA.
OKAY SO IN IN THAT DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGIES MARCH TWENTY
NINETEEN REPORT THERE WERE
FOURTEEN DEPARTMENTS.
USING CAL STARS OR THEIR LEGACY
SYSTEM YOU'RE SAYING NOW IT IS
FOUR AND CAL STARS [inaudible]
FIVE FTV DSS -- DUAL AND EDT ON
SOME OTHER LEGACY SYSTEM SO IT'S
NOW SEVEN DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE
ON GET THAT IS A FIVE IS CAL
STARS ANOTHER.
LEGACY THINGS ARE A LOT OKAY
[inaudible]
IT'S FIVE FIVE OH FIVE ON CAL
STARS.
THERE AND NO ONE ON AND ONE ON
THIS LEGACY SO. SIX SIX SIX IN
TOTAL OKAY AND ARE THERE ANY OF
THESE APARTMENTS STILL REPORTING
CONCERNS WITH USING FISCALE TO
MEET FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS.
THERE IS A COUPLE THAT.
THAT THE ISSUE THAT WAS
OUTSTANDING AS TO WHY THEY WERE
UTILIZING CAL STARS WAS FOR A
SPECIFIC REPORT.
THAT REPORT HAS BEEN AS FAR AS I
KNOW HAS BEEN WORKED OUT WITH
THE SCO AND THAT THE CONTROLLER
AND AND THE FEDS.
BUT THEY HAVE NOT -- I DON'T
KNOW IF THEY'VE SUBMITTED IT YET
SO AGAIN I WOULD BE MORE
APPROPRIATE FOR THE NEXT PARENTS
CIVIL ASSET NEXT TIME SO AND
THEN AND THERE PERHAPS.
THIS IS THE QUESTION THE NEXT
HOUSE ALBEIT AT WHAT IS THE
STATUS OF MONTH AND CLOSE PRO
ENTITY SO HOW MANY OF THESE
DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE.
USING THE SYSTEM ARE ACTUALLY
USING IT. TO PRODUCE TIMELY AND
ACCURATE SO NUMBERS IN MARCH I
HAD.
FORTY ABOUT 42% OF DEPARTMENTS.
ARE 40% AMOUNTS WERE CLOSED.
THAT NEEDED TO BE CLOSED AT THAT
POINT IN TIME.
TODAY SENT 42% OKAY DAY I'M UP
273% OKAY SO WE ARE AGAIN THOSE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES THAT WE'VE
BEEN ABLE.
TO MOVE IN SHIFT FROM OTHER
ACTIVITIES AND THEN WITH THE
AUGMENTATION THAT IS COMING IN
JULY ONE WE EXPECT TO BE ABLE TO
TO REALLY HAVE AXLES. FOR YOU
KNOW CLOSE 290% OF TOTAL
BUDGETARY EXPENDITURE SO THOSE
DEPARTMENTS THAT THE CLIP THAT
REPRESENT ABOUT 90% OF THE
BUDGET -- FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WILL BE ABLE TO CLOSE
WITH ACTUAL AND THAT'S WHEN
SORRY.
THAT'S BY WHEN THAT WILL BE BY
THE THE THE DATES THAT WERE SET
FORTH BY -- THAT BUT BY THE
CONTROLLER SO THERE'S SOME FUN
TO DO JULY -- ONE IN PSALM ARE
DUE AUGUST ONE OR AUGUST. THIRTY
ONE AUGUST OKAY.
AND BUT THEN I KNOW THAT IN THE
PAST WE HAVE.
HAD REALLY UNTIL ABOUT OCTOBER
FIRST OF SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH
BEFORE THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE
AND THAT THE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE START WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT TO DO ESTIMATES SO.
THAT BY THAT TIME FRAME IS WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT SO TRY TO GET
AS MANY AS WE CAN BY THE THE
REQUIRED DEADLINES AND THEN ALSO.
TARGETING THOSE BIG DEPARTMENTS
ARE THOSE THOSE BIG DOLLAR VALUE
DEPARTMENTS -- THE ONES ARE MOST
MATERIAL TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THOSE.
ARE RECEIVING THE BULK OF OUR
ATTENTION.
SO WHAT THAT MEANS THAT THERE
ARE SOME THAT WE'VE ANALYZED AND
BASED ON EITHER HISTORY -- SIZE
OR COMPLEXITY OR VACANCY RATES
ARE THERE'S A NUMBER OF THINGS
THAT WE LOOKED AT THERE WILL BE
ABOUT -- THIRTY DEPARTMENTS THAT
WE EXPECT WILL BE DOING.
ESTIMATES THAT WE'RE WE'RE
FAIRLY CONFIDENT WE'LL BE DOING
ESTIMATES.
AND THAT'S NOT A BAD THING WHEN
YOU SEE THAT THEY REPRESENT.
YOU KNOW WHAT.
LESS THAN A FEW PERCENT OF THE
TOTAL EXPENDITURES FOR THE STATE
THEY'RE NOT FEDERALLY FUNDED
DEPARTMENTS SO WILD THE GOAL IS
YOU KNOW NEXT YEAR TO BE ABLE TO
TO HAVE THEM ALL.
YEAH WITH A VERY THICK THERE'S
ALWAYS SOME THAT THEY DON'T.
BUT WHAT WE WANT TO BE PUTTING
THEM IN A POSITION WHERE THEY'RE
ABLE.
TO SOMETIMES DEPARTMENTS DON'T
CLOSE FOR THINGS OUTSIDE OF
FISCAL.
AND AGAIN FISCAL HAS BROUGHT
THESE THINGS TO LIGHT SO THERE
ARE CERTAIN -- THINGS THAT ARE
ACCEPTABLE -- ACCOUNTING
PRACTICES THAT SOMETIMES YOU
KNOW DEPARTMENTS HAVE BEEN DOING
THEM SLIGHTLY DIFFERENTLY OR NOT
EXACTLY RIGHT AS OF NOW THEY'RE
HAVING TO GO BACK INTO A LOT OF
RECONCILIATION WORK.
AGAIN BY THE SECOND OR THIRD
YEAR UTILIZING THE SYSTEM.
THERE IS THIS LEARNING CURVE AND
THE DEPARTMENTS ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY.
BETTER POSITIONS TO BE ABLE TO
GET THEIR THEIR WORK DONE IN A
MORE TIMELY FASHION.
SO -- OKAY GREAT THANK YOU ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS FOR THE DIRECTOR
OF THE REALLY FUN MR FUNG.
I THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE FOR
SO FOR MOST -- I GUESS AT CAN I
WE TALKED THE A YESTERDAY AND
YOU INDICATED THEIR NUMBER
AGENCIES THAT THAT CURRENTLY ARE
EXAM THIRD ARE NOT USING
UTILIZING FISCAL NOW.
WHAT ARE THOSE AGENCIES I THINK
YOU YOU TRY LIST THEM OFF FOR
BUT I THINK YOU MISSED A COUPLE
SO I SAW THE RECORDS I DIDN'T
WRITE THEM DOWN LET'S SEE I CAN
DO THEM TODAY IF NOT? FOR I'VE
GOT FOLKS BEHIND ME THEY CAN'T
SO THE EXEMPT WINDS WOULD BE THE
LEGISLATURE HERS STIRRERS AND
THE UC SYSTEM THOSE ONES ARE
NEVER EXPECTED TO COME ON TO OUR
SYSTEM.
THE ONES THAT ARE DEFERRED
INCLUDE CALTRANS DMV THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES.
I CDC ARE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
I'M AT FIVE CDT THE DEPARTMENT
OF TECHNOLOGY [inaudible]
OKAY.
REHAB THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION.
IS THAT ALL OF THEM.
I GET A WE GET A YES THEY'RE NOT
AND SO SEVEN AND THEN IN TERMS
OF AND NOT AS THEIR DEFERRED.
DENTAL WHAT IS THE TIME LINE FOR
THEM TO COME ON BOARD.
WE'RE EXPECTING CD T. TO COME ON
IN JULY OF TWENTY TWENTY THERE
ARE SMALLER DEPARTMENT AND WERE
ABLE TO ON BOARD THAT -- JUST
THROUGH THROUGH OUR REGULAR
PROCESS IN A REGULAR RESOURCES
WE ARE LOOKING AT DOING A GAP
ANALYSIS THIS YEAR WITH THE
OTHER LARGER DEPARTMENTS.
SO.
MY EARLY INDICATIONS FROM THEM
IS THAT LIKELY CALTRANS WILL BE
ONE OF THE NEXT ONES TO CALM
BECAUSE THEY'RE NEARING THE END
OF THE USEFUL LIFE OF THEIR ERP
SYSTEM THEIR EXISTING SYSTEM.
SO WE WILL BE DOING -- A
COORDINATED EFFORT WITH THEM TO
SEE WHAT WHAT ARE THE TYPES OF
ACCOUNTING NEEDS THAT YOU HAVE
OR OTHER PROJECT MANAGEMENT
NEEDS.
AND WHAT ARE THE THINGS ARE
CURRENTLY AVAILABLE IN FISCAL
WHAT MIGHT BE THAT GAP -- TO
KNOW WHAT ADJUSTMENTS OR WHAT
MODELS I MIGHT NEED TO BRING ON
OR WHAT CHANGES THAT THEY MAY
NEED TO MAKE.
SO.
MY EXPECTATION IS THAT WITH SOME
OF THE LARGER DEPARTMENTS
INCLUDING CALTRANS INCLUDING CDC
ARE.
THAT WITH THEIR I. WHEN THEY DO
COME ON WE WILL BE COMING TO THE
LEGISLATURE IN ASKING FOR FOR
RESOURCES FOR THAT ON BOARDING
EFFORT JUST BECAUSE THEY ARE SO
INCREDIBLY LARGE.
AND WE ARE -- WE ARE WINDING
DOWN THE SIZE OF MY CONTRACTING
STAFF AND AND SO SOME OF THAT
WORK THAT WE WOULD NEED TO BRING
BACK CONTRACTORS FOR ONE TIME
EFFORTS WE WOULD WANT TO DO THAT
AGAIN SO -- WITH THE WITH THE
SIZE OF THESE AGENCIES I MEAN
THAT THERE'S SUBSTANTIAL WORK
THEN LEFT TO DO.
YES WE HAVE 65% OF TOTAL
BUDGETARY EXPENDITURES CURRENTLY
IN THE SYSTEMS OF SOME OF THE
BIG DEPARTMENTS ARE STILL
OUTSIDE THE SYSTEM.
WHEN THE STATE CONTROLLER'S --
OFFICE COMES FULLY ONLINE WITH
THE CASH RECORDS WE WILL HAVE
SOME HIGH LEVEL INFORMATION ON
THE SAME LEVEL OF THE CONTROLLER
HAS TODAY WE'LL HAVE THAT HIGH
LEVEL IN OUR SYSTEM -- THAT
WOULD BE AVAILABLE VIA OUR OUR
TRANSPARENCY SITE BUT BUT NOT.
THE LEVEL OF DETAIL THAT WE HAVE
ON THOSE HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO
DEPARTMENTS ARE CURRENTLY IN THE
SYSTEM SO.
IT WILL AT YOUR YOU ARE CORRECT
IN THAT IT'LL BE A FEW YEARS
BEFORE WE HAVE THAT SAME LEVEL
OF DETAIL.
SO THEN IN TERMS OF I GUESS
MAYBE YOU CAN EXPLAIN TO ME THAT
I UNDERSTAND THERE'S A STEERING
COMMITTEE THAT OVERSEES THE THIS
PROJECT.
HOW DOES IT INTERACTION AND
WHO'S THE ULTIMATE -- WHO'S
ACCOUNTABLE AND IN TERMS OF THE
OF OVERSIGHT OF FISCAL AND AND
HOW THE STEERING COMMITTEE
COMMITTEE OPERATES.
NO TAKE THAT I WITH RESPECT YOUR
QUESTION SIR I AM RESPONSIBLE ON
THE PROJECT SPONSOR AND CHIEF
OPERATING OFFICER DEPARTMENT
FINANCE AND SO. TO TO YOUR POINT
THAT WOULD BE ME OKAY SO THEN
SAID IN THE STEERING COMMITTEE
MEETS AND THEN THEY REPORT TO
YOU THAT WORKS NOT NOW BUT YOU
HAVE TO THE ULTIMATE RESPONSIBLE
THAT THE STEERING COMMITTEE IN
OUR CHARTER WE WE MAKE --
DECISIONS AS A GROUP THAT BY
CONSENSUS OKAY SO -- THAT
OPERATE SORT OF LIKE THE UNITED
NATIONS SECURITY COUNCIL NOT
REGARD.
I'M NOT SURE THAT IS THE EXAMPLE
THAT YOU WANT TO USE -- YOU MAY
WANT TO REVISE YOUR CHANCE --
OKAY SO IN IN TERMS OF FROM FROM
THAT SAMPLE AND THEN AND THEN
WHAT IS THE INTERACTION BETWEEN --
AND AS YOU TEACH HERE THE CVT
AND AND THIS CALENDAR DEPART
FINANCE.
SO THE THE WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
OVERSIGHT ENTITIES THAT THE
PROVIDE OUTSIDE.
OVERVIEW SO THE DEPARTMENT OF I
A TECHNOLOGY PROVIDES
INDEPENDENT PROJECT OVERSIGHT I
PET WHICH WHICH FRANCISCO CAN
SPEAK TALE -- AND AGAIN THEY'RE
THEY'RE OVER SEEING KIND OF OUR
PROJECT MANAGEMENT AND HOW WE
ARE STAYING -- IN LINE WITH
SCOPE SCHEDULE TYPES OF THINGS
BUT I ALSO HAVE INDEPENDENT
VALIDATION AND VERIFICATION
WHICH IS AN INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTS THAT -- IS RUNNING TO
HELP US WITH THE TECHNOLOGY
TECHNOLOGICAL PIECES ARE WE
MAKING DECISIONS THAT ARE
TECHNOLOGICALLY SOUND IS THE
SYSTEM GOING TO TO FUNCTION --
AND THEN WE ALSO HAVE THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S THE CSA
ALSO DO PROVIDE SOME LEVEL OF
OVERSIGHT OF COURSE THE
LEGISLATURE WHERE -- WHERE I
SPENT QUITE A TIME THIS THIS
YEAR?
AND THEN -- SO THAT THAT --
TODAY IN TERMS OF THIS AND THIS
IS PROBABLY NOT MAYBE IS OUTSIDE
THE SCOPE OF THE HEARING ABOUT.
THIS NEW -- DID YOU INNOVATION
AGENTS OR OFFICE HAS BEEN
CREATED HOW DOES THAT HOW DOES
THAT FIT IN TEND TO YOUR THE
STEERING COMMITTEE AND THE
OVERSIGHT AND AND WHAT IS THEIR
ROLE -- IN FISCAL IF AT ALL.
SO AGAIN RIDICULE AND DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE.
ODI AS PROPOSED AND FOR FIRST OF
ALL THE THE PROJECT WILL BE DONE.
TO SORT OF ABOUT THE SAME TIME
ODIS GETTING OFF THE GROUND IT
DOESN'T TAKE EFFECT UNTIL JULY
ONE AND THEY HAVE TO SORT OF
BUILD THE ORGANIZATION AND
THAT'S GONNA BE STARTED OUT
TELLING ABOUT THE TIME FISCALES
WANTING DOWN.
AYE AYE BUT I JUST FOR CONTACT
SOMEONE -- PROVIDE A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE ON WHERE WE ARE
TODAY I THIS GIRL IS THE
TECHNOLOGY IS BUILT AND IT'S
DEPLOYED THE PROJECT IS DEPLOYED --
WE DON'T HAVE TECHNOLOGY
CHALLENGES PER SE WITH THIS GUY
WHAT WE HAVE THIS IS A MASSIVE
HUMAN CHANGE MANAGEMENT EFFORT
AT THIS POINT -- AND AND WITH
THE BENEFIT OF HINDSIGHT NOT
EXPERIENCE WE WE PROBABLY SHOULD
COME OUT OF THE GATE A LITTLE
STRONGER ON CHANGE MANAGEMENT --
BUT WE RECOGNIZE THAT ALONG THE
WAY WE'VE LISTENED OUR
DEPARTMENTS WE LISTEN TO OUR
OVERSIGHT ENTITIES -- AND OUR
CUSTOMERS -- I WAS ONE UNTIL I
CAME BACK TO FINANCE SIX EIGHT
MONTHS AGO I WAS IT DIRECTOR
COLLEGE ART I WAS A CUSTOMER IF
THE SCOUTS I I KNOW I KNOW THE
PAIN POINT FROM BOTH SIDES --
AND SO WHAT THE LEGISLATURE
SUPPORT AND AND OUR OUR SPRING
LETTER THIS YEAR THAT THIS IS
ALL ABOUT DOUBLING DOWN ON
CHANGE MANAGEMENT THAT'S ABOUT
INVESTING IN OUR WORK FORCE AND
IT'S ABOUT.
KNOWLEDGE TRANSFER FROM OUR
CONTRACTED RESOURCES TO OUR
STATE WORKFORCE AND SO THAT
THAT'S WHERE OUR EFFORTS REALLY
ARE TODAY -- IS BUSINESS
INTERNET -- POINTED OUT THAT
THERE IS THIS IS THIS IS A
COMPLEX PROJECT YOU KNOW THAT
THAT THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE FOR
US TO SCALE.
WE HAVE A WORKFORCE OF A QUARTER
MILLION WE HAVE A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY PLUS APARTMENTS BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS WE HAVE TWENTY
THOUSAND SYSTEM USERS.
THIS IS A MASSIVE UNDERTAKING SO.
SO BUT AT THIS POINT WHERE WE'RE
LOOKING AT ONE CHANGE MANAGEMENT
BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE WE ARE OKAY
SO THEN BUT AS THEY DOVE TELL ME
YOUR YOU'RE ADDING ON THE THE
DEFERRED -- AGENCIES RIGHT SO
CALTRANS EMITTED THE ONES YOU
LOVE TO CATCH AND YET DMV DDR
CDC ARE DOJ CD T. AND
REHABILITATION -- SO THEN.
DO YOU FORESEE ADDITIONAL
CHALLENGES ARE IS A MAIN I GUESS.
THIS GUY OUT IS NOT TECHNICALLY
WINDING DOWN IF YOU'RE ME THE
ONE DOWN IN TERMS OF THE YOUR
INITIAL SCOPE BUT YOU STILL HAVE
A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF WORK
LEFT TO DO.
AND AND WE CONTINUE TURN OVER
TIME WE WE WE ARE MAKING
IMPROVEMENTS CONSUL IN THE
PROJECT SO IS IS WE FOUND PAIN
POINTS FOR DEPARTMENTS WHETHER
WE CAN CREATE A NEW REPORT
AUTOMATE SOMETHING RECONCILE
SOMETHING AN AUTOMATED FASHION
WE'RE DOING THAT.
ALL THE TIME AND WE LOOK OF
RELEASING THOSE.
INTO PRODUCTION IN REAL TIME AND
SO SO WHAT WERE WHAT CHECKING
SOME OF THE PRESSURE OFF THAT
WAY BUT WE'RE ALSO MAKING SURE
THE STAFF HAVE THE SKILL SETS TO
DO WHAT THEY NEED TO DO -- SO SO
THERE'S ALWAYS GOING TO BE AN
ONGOING COMPRESS SO THAT IN
ITSELF FROM THE OTI PERSPECTIVE
TO THE EXTENT THAT THEY THEY AND
WE EXPECT THEM TO BRING NOVEL
IDEAS AND APPROACHES THE DIGITAL
SERVICE DELIVERY THAT.
THAT WE CAN TAKE THOSE AND WE
CAN INCORPORATE THAT INTO FISCAL
AS WE DO THESE ONGOING
ENHANCEMENTS ABSOLUTELY BUT BUT
SORT OF AS A AN IMMEDIATE THING
I DON'T TOUCH SO BUT YOU DON'T
YOU DON'T FOR SEE THEM BEING
PART OF THE STEERING COMMITTEE I
GUESS I AS A QUESTION.
IS -- I GUESS IN TERMS OF LIKE.
THE THE THE OVERSIGHT DO YOU SEE
THEM AS KIND OF ANOTHER
STAKEHOLDER OR ARE THEY JUST AN
ADVISORY ROLE AS WELL I MEAN
I'VE DOES JUST.
THAT WOULD BE AN ADVISOR ROLE IN
THE AND WE DON'T ANTICIPATE
ADDING THEM TO THE GOVERNMENT'S
MODEL AT THIS POINT OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU GUYS FOR YOUR JUST
READ CYNICAL QUESTION BECAUSE
YOU TOUCHED UPON THIS A LITTLE
BIT EARLIER -- WE MENTION SPRING
LETTER BUT ALSO THE BUDGET
ALLOCATION ANYTHING TO ACTUALLY --
FOR TRAINING FOR FOLKS PEOPLE
MOVING AWAY FROM THE LEGACY
SYSTEM ACTUALLY ON TO FACE CAL
COMPLETELY.
AND WHAT WAS THE ANTICIPATED --
TIMELINE FOR THAT WERE WE WERE
NO LONGER BE USING THE LEGACY
SYSTEMS AND COMPLETELY ON FISCAL
ALSO WE'RE NOT.
DOUBLING UP. TO THE SENATE.
THE DEPARTMENTS -- MIGHT HAVE
OTHER LEGACY SYSTEMS THEY DO
THINGS THAT ARE OUTSIDE THE
SCOPE OF THE OF THE FISCAL
SYSTEM.
I CAME FROM A DEPARTMENT THAT
THAT HAD ONE OF THOSE PRIOR TO I
TOO WAS A A USER OF THE FISCAL
SYSTEM.
PRIOR TO COMING TO SCALE -- SO
THERE ARE SOME OF THOSE THAT ARE
OUTSIDE JUST THE INITIAL SCOPE
AND AND WE WOULD HAVE TO TO
THINK ABOUT ARE THOSE THINGS
THAT WE WANT TO ADD ON BUT WITH
RESPECT TO THE FOUR PARTNERS AND
THEIR LEGACY SYSTEMS AND THEIR
LEGACY MAINFRAMES -- THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCES RETIRED FOUR
OF THAT CAN THE STATE
TREASURER'S OFFICE IS READY TO
RETIRE FOUR OF THEM BUT HASN'T
YET BECAUSE THERE'S ONE PIECE
THAT IS -- TIED TO THE
CONTROLLERS FUNCTIONALITY THAT
WILL BE COMING BY THE END OF
THIS YEAR.
AND THEN ONCE THE CONTROLLER
FUNCTIONALITY COMES ON WE HAVE
THIS THE EXPECTATION IS THAT
WE'RE GONNA RUN.
IN IN PARALLEL -- FOR AT LEAST
YOU KNOW FOR AT LEAST A YEAR TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
PRODUCE THE KAFFIR WITH A HIGH
CONFIDENCE RIGHT OUT OF OUR
SYSTEM AND AND BE ABLE TO
COMPARISON TO COMPARE THAT WITH.
THE CAFFERTY INCREASED OUT OF
THE LEGACY SYSTEM SO AGAIN THAT
ULTIMATE WHEN DO YOU DEPARTMENTS
OF THE CONTROL AGENCIES TURN OFF
THEIR LEGACY SYSTEMS.
THAT THAT'S MORE IN IN IN THEIR
COURT IT'S ONCE THEY FEEL THAT
WE HAVE BUILT ALL THE
FUNCTIONALITY AND CAPACITY
WITHIN HOURS -- AND LIKE I SAID
WE'RE 98% OF THE REQUIREMENTS
THAT WERE KNOWN REQUIREMENTS
THAT.
TODAY THAT I KNOW ABOUT -- THOSE
ARE HAVE BEEN ALREADY DEPLOYED
AND WITH RESPECT TO THE ANOTHER
LEGACY SYSTEM THAT WE EXPECT TO
BE RETIRED.
IS THE CAL STARS SYSTEM AND
WE'RE EXPECTING THAT ALSO TO BE
WINDING DOWN -- IN TWENTY
NINETEEN AS WELL AND AGAIN
THERE'S ONLY A FEW DEPARTMENTS
THAT ARE UTILIZING IT.
REMAINING AND IT BECOMES AS YOU
WERE YOU WERE ALLUDING TO IT
BECOMES JUST AT THE WORKLOAD.
FOR THE CONTROL AGENCIES OF THE
DEPARTMENTS THEMSELVES TO IT TO
BE HAVING A FOOT IN EACH DOOR.
ARE IN EACH SYSTEM -- IT'S IT'S
VERY BURDENSOME AND SO TO THE
EXTENT THAT WE CAN GET THOSE
APARTMENTS OFF OF CAL STARS WILL
BE NOT ONLY RELIEF TO TO THE
DEPARTMENTS BUT ALSO I WOULD.
PRESUME A RELIEF TO THE FOLKS AT
THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE THAT HAVE
TO SUPPORT THAT SYSTEM.
AND SO YOU MENTIONED THE RUN
AROUND A PERIL SYSTEM IS THAT
WITH THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE YES.
OKAY SO THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE WILL BE THE LAST.
OF THE INITIAL BATCH THE LAST
WANTS TO MOVE AWAY FROM THE
LEGACY SYSTEM.
AND SO WE ANTICIPATE THAT STILL
ANOTHER YEAR OUT [inaudible]
GEORGE BUSH [inaudible]
POSSIBLY.
MOST LIKELY.
THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY NO MORE
LEGACY SYSTEM.
I'M GEORGE LEWIS ON THE CHIEF
OPERATING OFFICER THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE AND
ASSUMING WE DON'T HAVE ANY
HICCUPS AND NO ISSUES AND WERE
SATISFIED IN THE STATE AUDITOR'S
SATISFIED.
YES.
THANK YOU KNOW I'M JUST THINKING
IN TERMS OF THE BUDGET.
SO THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE ON
SO JUST IN TERMS CHANGE
MANAGEMENT SO SO ARE YOU.
ON MEETING THAT I HAVE RIGHT NOW
THE TECHNOLOGY HAS BEEN DEPLOYED.
BUT YOU HAVE.
TO TRAIN PEOPLE HOW TO USE IT
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO USE IT YOUR
YOUR FACING SOME RESISTANCE IN
TERMS OF CHANGING WHICH I WOULD
ANTICIPATE PEOPLE ARE PEOPLE ARE
GENERALLY COMFORTABLE WITH A
SYSTEM AND IT'S YOU KNOW LIKE IF
YOU ASKED US ALL.
TO GET OFF OF MICROSOFT WORD AND
GO USE SOMETHING ELSE TOMORROW
YEAH YOU WOULD YOU WOULD FACE
RESISTANCE I JUST.
IS REALITY EVEN OTHER COMPARABLE
SYSTEMS EXACT SORT OF WHAT
YOU'RE IN FOR ABSOLUTELY SIR AND
AND AND YOU KNOW HUMANS HUMANS
DON'T REACT THE CHAINS.
THAT WELL SOME DO BETTER THAN
OTHERS -- GOVERNMENT'S NOT VERY
GOOD AT CHANGE MANAGEMENT
BECAUSE WE DON'T TEND TO THINK
OF THE HUMAN ASPECT OF OUR
ACTIONS WE JUST WE'RE GOVERNMENT
WE DO THINGS THE WAY WE DO
THINGS AND EVERYBODY SORT HAS TO
CONFORM TO THAT.
AND THEN THAT'S COUPLED WITH AN
ENVIRONMENT.
LARGE IN OUR ACCOUNTING STAFF
THAT THEY THEY'VE OPERATED IN
AND IN A SYSTEM AND OUT WORLD
FOR DECADES AND AND THEN WE
WOULD DROP THIS MASSIVE NEW
SYSTEM ON THEM THAT.
HAS A LOT OF COMPLEXITY LOT MORE
DETAIL WHICH BRINGS WITH IT
TRANSPARENCY TRANSPARENCY COMES
AT A COST -- SO SO THERE'S
WORKLOAD THERE THERE'S NEW WAYS
OF DOING BUSINESS -- AND THEN
WE'RE FINDING OUT AS WE ROLLING
THIS OUT THAT THERE'S CERTAIN
THINGS THAT THESE DEPARTMENTS
NEED THAT.
WITH THE NEXT THING ALSO WERE
BUILDING SOME OF THAT FOR THEM
TO MAKE THEIR LIFE IS A SO IT'S
SO IT'S ALL THAT'S WHAT'S THE
EARLY OUT REACH ITS ENGAGEMENTS
GETTING THEIR INPUT INTO THE
SYSTEM DESIGN AND HOW IT WORKS.
IT'S BRING AMENDED TRYING THEM
ON SITE TEST GIVE US FEEDBACK
ITERATE AND AND SUPPORT AMONG
ROLLED OUT LIVE IT'S ALL OF
THOSE THINGS -- SUITS WHICH
DEPARTMENT WOULD YOU SAY ARE THE
FURTHEST ALONG THAT CURVE CHANGE
MANAGEMENT -- WE HAVE A NUMBER
THAT -- ARE CLOSING ON A ON A
REGULAR AND CONSISTANT BASIS SO --
YEAH THE PARTNERS ARE VERY FAR
ALONG ON THAT BUT I'D SAY THAT
THAT CALIFORNIA'S FAR AND THEY
WERE TWENTY EIGHTEEN RELEASE
DEPARTMENT -- AND THEN I HAVE
SOME THAT WERE IN MY WAVE ONE
THAT ARE LAGGING BEHIND THE
CURVE ON IT.
AND IN THEIR INSTANCES THEY'VE
HAD SIGNIFICANT -- TURN OF
RATIONS IT'S NOT.
IT'S BECAUSE OUR SMALL
DEPARTMENT YOU LOSE ONE PERSON%
YOU'VE LOST YOU KNOW 20% OF YOUR
ACCOUNTING STAFF OR OR MORE IN
SOME CASES.
AND SO THAT LEARNING CURVE IS
YOU KNOW A DIFFERENT CHALLENGE
FOR FOR SOME OF THOSE
DEPARTMENTS BUT WE DO HAVE QUITE
A FEW I MEAN F. T. B. EVEN
THOUGH THEY'RE GONNA BE CLOSING
IN LEGACY.
THEY HAVE BEEN EXCELLING IN THIS
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
HAS BEEN -- K. PUSHING.
PUSHING AHEAD AND SOME OF THOSE
WERE I MENTION BECAUSE THEY THEY
WERE SURPRISING TO ME THEY WERE
THE ONES THAT I HAD ON MY RADAR
AS ALL MY GOSH I I THESE ARE
THINGS THAT THAT ABSOLUTELY
CANNOT FAIL WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THESE DEPARTMENTS.
ARE SUCCESSFUL CHP IS ANOTHER
ONE IT WAS A TWENTY EIGHTEEN
DEPARTMENT THAT -- WE'RE NOT
EVEN PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO HELP THEM BECAUSE
THEY ARE SOMEONE TOP OF THAT
THEY HAVEN'T HAD -- ANY ISSUE SO
SO THERE'S DEFINITELY
DEPARTMENTS THAT IN AGAIN.
DESPITE WHAT I THINK SOME OF THE
ORIGINAL THINKING WAS WE'RE
GONNA BRING ON THE SMALL
DEPARTMENTS AND AND WE LEARNED
FROM CONTROL AGENCY ANNA AND THE
PROJECT.
BUT HAD WE BROUGHT IN THE LARGER
DEPARTMENTS FIRST I THINK THAT
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN EASIER HOLE
FOR THE SMALLER ONES BECAUSE WE
WOULD HAVE.
BECAUSE THERE'S MORE
SOPHISTICATION IN THESE LARGER
DEPARTMENTS AND THERE'S MORE TO
ACCOUNTING THAT NEEDED TO HAPPEN
MORE COMPLEXITY SO THE ISSUES
THAT THAT WE'RE IDENTIFYING WE
WOULD HAVE IDENTIFIED.
EARLIER IN THE CURRENT AND IN
REGARDS TO CAL FIRE WHAT WHAT
WOULD YOU THINK MADE THEN.
ADOPT OR WHAT WHAT WHAT MADE
THEM SUCCESSFUL.
BOTH CAL FIRE IN C. H. P. HAD A
DESIGNATED.
SENIOR PERSON WHO OWNS THIS GUY
IT WAS THEIR JOB TO BRING THEIR
DEPARTMENT -- ON TO FISCAL.
AND THEY WERE GIVEN THE
AUTHORITY.
AND THE RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO
DO THAT SO WITH THE WITH CAL
FIRE THEY HAVE -- INVESTED
BECAUSE THEY'RE ONE OF THOSE
DISPERSED DEPARTMENTS SAID
THEY'VE GOT OFFICES IN AN
ACCOUNTING HAPPENING ALL UP AND
DOWN THE STATE YOU THINK THAT
WOULD BE HARDER THEY HAVE HAD
THIS INDIVIDUAL HAS TRAVELED UP
AND DOWN THE STATE THEY HAVE
BEEN DOING CHANGE MANAGEMENT.
FOR ALMOST TWO YEARS -- AND SO
IT WASN'T JUST WHEN WE STARTED
ENGAGING
IT'S THAT HAVE LIKE
THAT SINGLE POINT OF CONTACT.
AND THEY AREN'T.
THE THE SPONSOR THE VANDALS BUT
BUT THEY ARE THE ONES THAT ARE
THE DECISION MAKERS THOSE
DEPARTMENTS STRUGGLE MICHAEL.
BECAUSE EVERYTHING IS A SINGLE
BOTTLENECK IN THAT CASE SO WE'VE
TAKEN THE SPONSOR TO AN EXTRA IN
WHERE THEY ARE THE ONLY ONES
THAT CAN MAKE DECISIONS AND
THOSE DEPARTMENTS CONTINUE TO
STRUGGLE.
IT ENDED IN TERMS OF AND SO AS
YOU DEAL WITH THESE DEPARTMENTS
AND THERE BY AND ARE YOU.
ARE YOU WILL BE LOOKING AT THE
YOUR THAT THAT PROJECT LEADER.
IN EACH DEPARTMENT IS SWITCHING
UP THOSE PEOPLE OR WHAT WHAT HOW
ARE YOU APPROACHING AT THAT
AGAIN THAT'S THAT DEPENDENT
APARTMENTS GET TO MAKE THEIR
ASSIGNMENTS AS TO WHO WORKS ON
THESE TYPES OF EFFORTS.
BUT AS PART OF OUR CHANGE
MANAGEMENT AS PART OF US GOING
OUT INTO THE DEPARTMENTS -- WERE
DOING THINGS LIKE HELPING THEM --
IDENTIFY THEIR WE HAVE SUPER
USER FORM SO FOLKS THAT KNOW
MULTIPLE MODULES WITHIN EACH OF
THE DEPARTMENTS [inaudible]
DOING -- YOU KNOW A POSTERS WITH
THEIR PICTURES ON IT BECAUSE I
CANNOT TELL YOU HOW MANY
DEPARTMENTS WE'VE GONE INTO I
DON'T EVEN KNOW WHO MY SUPER
USER IT.
THESE ARE YOUR FIRST YOU'RE KIND
OF POINT ZERO THESE ARE THE
FOLKS THAT WE HAVE INVESTED THE
EXTRA TRAINING IN WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT ALL OF YOU ARE
ARE ARE LEVERAGING AND UTILIZING
THIS.
SO WE'RE WORKING ON A CAMPAIGN
WITH WITH THE DEPARTMENT TO BE
ABLE.
TO GIVE MORE VISIBILITY INTO
THOSE PEOPLE THAT HAVE THE SKILL
SET AND THEN ALSO -- PROVIDE
THOSE SUPER USERS -- MORGAN
EXPRESS LINE IF YOU WILL IN TO
MY HELP DESK AND INTO MY
BUSINESS SERVICES TEAM SO THAT.
AGAIN WERE REINFORCING THAT WE
NEED MORE PEOPLE IN THE
DEPARTMENTS BETTER TAKING
OWNERSHIP IN AND AND COMING UP
WITH A SOLUTION TO THE PROBLEM.
SO WE ARE WORKING WITH THEM TO
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'VE GOT THE
RIGHT LEVEL OF COMMITMENT IN
THOSE DEPARTMENTS.
AND THEN FIRST WAS TWO PARTS
PARTICULAR SO CDC ARE AND SAY
CALTRANS I KNOW CDC ARE HAS A
HAS A NEWER SYSTEM.
SO IT'S NOT TOTALLY INTEGRATED
IT'S JUST TO INTERFACE A HOUSE
HOW DOES THAT WORK WITH.
SISTEMA DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE --
DEPLOYED BUT THEY THEY AND THEY
HAVE THEIR OWN SYSTEM WHERE
YOU'RE JUST THE SYSTEM TO JUST
SORT OF TALKING TO EACH OTHER.
WITH THE RIGHT NOW OUR
INTERFACING INTO THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE ON THE
ACCOUNTING.
AND IT'S AT THE HIGH LEVEL THAT
THOSE INTERFACES EXIST WHEN A
CONTROLLER COMES ON THOSE
INTERFACES WILL BE POINTED YEAH
MOVED FROM THEIR LEGACY INTO MY
SYSTEM.
BUT IT'LL STILL BE THAT HIGH
LEVEL OF CAPTURE.
IT'S NOT UNTIL WE USE A HIGH
LEVEL MEETING TO SINCE YOU DON'T
YOU DON'T SEE F. T. E. ZERO C.
POSITIONS JUST.
JUST BROAD BRUSH EXPENDITURES
I'M IN THE PAST THAT I DON'T
KNOW WHAT LEVEL OF DETAIL YOU
GUYS CAPTURE I DON'T.
I DON'T THINK IT'S GOING TO BE
AT THAT LEVEL OF DETAIL UNTIL
THEY'RE ACTUALLY ON FISCAL.
GOING TO BE MORE OF A SUMMARY
LEVEL.
SOME OF THE LIKE WE SPENT THIS
MUCH MONEY AND WE GOT THIS MONEY
LIKE WHEN YOU SEE SOME ELECT
FIVE LINE ITEM TO DOCUMENT ON
I'LL BE MORE NAP BUT IT'S NOT
GOING TO BE THE KIND OF DETAIL
WHERE YOU CAN BE ABLE TO SEE HOW
MUCH THEY SPENT.
ON ON FRUITS AND VEGETABLES FOR
EXAMPLE HERE SAYS.
A MUCH BROADER ARM OF LEVEL LIKE
MAYBE FOOD RIGHT.
WHAT WHAT WHAT WE'RE DOING PC
HIS ON AFTER ANNOUNCEMENT BUT
JUST HAVE SO IT'S LIKE SO CAN WE
SEE ALL THE DIFFERENT?
BC PEAS AND WORK WHERE THEY'RE
GOING.
ON THE BUDGET SIDE -- I JUST SIX
I DIDN'T.
LIKE THAT LIKE SO FOR US WE GET
A LOT OF BUDGETARY PROPOSALS.
THAT THOSE ARE ALL SORT OF TIED
TO PRIMARILY HEAD COUNT.
AND SO DO WE DO WE SEE.
WOULD WE SEE BE ABLE TO SEE THAT
IN FRISCO IN THE BUDGET.
AND THE BUDGET SIDE ABSOLUTELY
ON THE BUDGET SIDE BUT NOT AS ON
THE DEPARTMENT HE SOMEONE ON A
COUNTY.
RIGHT WOULDN'T COME TO US ON THE
ACCOUNT GOT.
SO FISCAL HAS BOTH -- FISCAL HAS
BOTH THE HYPERION PLATFORM IN
SYSTEM THAT WE DO THE BUDGET ON
AND THAT THE PEOPLE SOFT AS TO
WHAT WE DO THE ACCOUNTING SIDE.
GOT IT -- AND SO THEN FOR THE
ACCOUNTING SOFTWARE THAN WITH
THEIR IT IS A GOAL TO HAVE A
MORE.
SAY DETAILED BREAKDOWN OF CDC
ARE OR CALTRANS VEGAS WHERE
WHERE IS THIS GOING.
YES I MEAN THE THE LEVEL OF
DETAIL WE HAVE CURRENTLY IN THE
SYSTEM IN THIS IS AGAIN A GOOD
CONVERSATION I THINK FOR THE
SECOND PANEL -- BUT THE THE
LEVEL OF DETAIL THAT THE
APARTMENTS CAN RECORD
INFORMATION IN IN OUR SYSTEM CAN
BE IT IS QUITE.
A FINE LEVEL NOW IS THAT.
THE LEVEL WE WANT. TO REQUIRE
DEPARTMENTS TO TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION GIVEN THE THE FLIP
SIDE WHICH IS THE WORKLOAD AND
WHAT IS THE VALUE OF KNOWING
THAT IT'S A GALA APPLE VERSES OF
FUJI APPLE.
OR GRANNY SMITH APPLE YOU KNOW.
SO SO THERE HAS TO BE KIND OF
THAT BALANCE OF AT WHAT LEVEL OF
DETAIL DO YOU WANT THAT BUT THE
SYSTEM HAS THE ABILITY TO
CAPTURE AT A VERY FINE.
OKAY IF I CAN JUST ADD ON THAT
SIR -- IT WAS THAT I WAS
INVOLVED IN THE EARLY PLANNING
OF THIS PROJECT TWELVE FOURTEEN
YEARS AGO AND AND THAT THAT TIME.
THE ADMINISTRATION BACK THEN AND
WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE WE HAD
A FEW BIG DEPARTMENTS THAT THAT
NEEDED TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
ACCOUNTING SYSTEMS WITH THE RP
SYSTEMS AND BUT WE ALSO KNOW
WE'RE TRYING TO PUT SOMETHING
FROM STATEWIDE PERSPECTIVE BUT
IT THE DECISION THAT MADE AT THE
TIME THAT.
YOU KNOW CALTRANS IS SO BIG
CITIES ARE SO BIG THEY HAVE
THEIR OWN ECONOMIES OF SCALE
THAT IT WAS WORTH IT TO INVEST
IN THOSE SYSTEMS AT THAT TIME.
KNOWING THAT AT SOME POINT DOWN
THE ROAD WE WOULD BE THE
STATEWIDE SYSTEM AND EVENTUALLY
WE WE WOULD BRING THEM INTO THE
FOLD THIS WAS PLANNED ALLALONG
THIS WAS IT WAS IT WAS
UNDERSTOOD IN THE EARLY PLANNING
STAGES.
AND AND IT'S STILL OUR PLANET
WHEN WHEN IT'S TIME TO REPLACE
THOSE THE OUR PEACE THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO REPLACE MY PLAN IS TO
ROLL THEM INTO FISCAL UNABLE TO
HAVE FULL FUNCTIONALITY THAT
POINT FACTOR UNDERLYING QUESTION.
WELL THE LARGEST COST FOR US IS
A STATE IS ON PERSONNEL AND IN A
STAFFING ACOSTA WELL.
WILL WE SEE THAT FROM A
DEPARTMENT LEVEL.
IT DOES THIS THE PERSONAL COSTS
ARE IN THE BUDGET THEY'RE IN THE
BUDGET ACT IN AND I WOULD JUST
ADD ANOTHER THING TO DISCUSS
BROUGHT TO US AND I THINK MISSES
ME DON'T COVER IN OUR OPENING
BUT THIS THE PAST THREE BUDGETS
AND THIS NEXT BUDGET WHEN IT'S
DONE -- WILL BE AT A LEVEL OF
DETAIL THAT BE DONE IN THE
SYSTEM AND A LITTLE DETAIL TO
THE LEGISLATURE IN THE PUBLIC
THAT IS THE SAME UPDATE THAT WE
PURCHASE PREVIOUSLY COULD ONLY
PROVIDE THE JAN TEN BUDGET.
SO -- SO THAT STUFF IS THERE AND
IS AVAILABLE TO THE WORLD TO SEE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BEFORE WE WE DIG INTO OUR SECOND
PANEL AND GET INTO THE DETAILS
AROUND THIS STATE COUNTY AND
OVERSIGHT.
I DID JUST WANT TO CHECK IN WITH
OUR OTHER PANELISTS AND SEE IF
YOU HAVE.
ANYTHING TO ADD -- AND THEN THE
HIGHER LEVEL TOPIC AS FISCALES
IMPLEMENTATION IN STATUS THAT
YOU COULD BE USEFUL FOR THE
COMMITTEE. TO NOW.
JUST BRIEFLY WANTED TO SPEAK AS
YOU MENTIONED THE CONTROLLERS
LETTER SAID IN YOUR OPENING --
THE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE IS.
FULLY COMMITTED TO SEEING THIS
PROJECT THROUGH TO ITS
COMPLETION AND SUCCESSFUL
COMPLETION DOUBLE CONTROLLERS
LETTER WAS IN NO WAY INTENDED TO
IMPLY THAT.
SHE WAS NOT COMMITTED. TO NOT
SURE IF YOU'RE MIKE IS ON TRY
THIS.
ONE THIS ONE BETTER.
OKAY SO THE CONTROLLERS LETTER
WAS NO WAY INTENDED TO IMPLY
THAT SHE IS NOT COMMITTED TO THE
PROJECT -- OR THAT SHE FEELS
THAT WE NEED TO BACK OUT OF THE
PROJECT SHE IS FULLY COMMITTED.
TO SUCCESSFUL COMPLETION.
THE CONTROLLERS LETTER AND HER
CONCERNS WERE BASICALLY AROUND
SOME OF THE TIMELINESS ISSUES
REGARDING THE BOOK A RECORD
BECAUSE OF THE INTERFACES THAT
WERE MENTIONED EARLIER -- AS WE
MENTIONED THE INTERFACES CAUSED
SOME ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD. TO THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE STAFF WERE
SOME OF THE CASH REMITTANCES
COULDN'T BE CAPTURED AS TIMELY
AS WE WOULD HAVE NEEDED.
TO ON THE LEGACY SIDE ON THE FOR
THE BOOK A RECORD.
AND THEREFORE WE PRODUCE THAT
CASH REPORT THAT MONTH THE
NUMBERS WERE SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER
AND THAN WHAT SOME OF THE OTHER
REPORTS WERE SHOWING SUCH THAT'S
WHAT HER CONCERN WAS ABOUT THAT
WE NEED A TIME TO MAKE SURE.
THAT THIS OUR WORKLOAD WAS ABLE
TO BE PROCESSED WE NEED SOME
ASSISTANCE FROM A PROJECT TO
CREATE THESE ENHANCEMENTS THAT
WE NEEDED TO BE ABLE.
TO GET THIS WORK DONE.
AND WE NEED IT TO BE ABLE TO
SLOW DOWN AND WE USE THE TERM
STABILIZATION EVEN ON THAT MAY
NOT HAVE BEEN COMPLETELY
ACCURATE STABILIZE THE SYSTEM IF
YOU WILL.
SO THAT THE CASH MANAGEMENT
STAFF CAN ACTUALLY DO THEIR WORK
AND HAVE.
NUMBERS IN THE BOOK OF RECORD
THAT THEY CAN TRUST THAT'S WHAT
IT WAS ALL ABOUT.
AND WE WORK TOGETHER WITH THE
PROJECT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND WE DID COME UP WITH SOME
SOLUTIONS TO TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
AND IT IS WORKING BETTER AT THE
TIME THAT CASH MANAGEMENT STAFF
WERE SPENDING IN PROCESSING
REMITTANCES.
HAS GONE DOWN FROM A MAXIMUM OF
FIFTEEN DAYS AND WE'RE DOWN TO
THREE DAYS RIGHT NOW BECAUSE OF
ALL THE STABILIZATION EFFORT SO
WE WANT TO GET DOWN TO ONE DAY
WHICH IS WHAT OUR GOAL HAS
ALWAYS BEEN.
HOWEVER IT IS GETTING BETTER --
SO THAT'S WHAT THE LETTER WAS
ABOUT IT WASN'T TO IMPLY THAT
THE PROJECT IS A FAILURE OR TO
IMPLY THAT WE'RE NOT COMMITTED
TO IT AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO SEE
IT THROUGH.
THESE INTERFACES THE PARALLEL
SYSTEM THAT WE'VE DISCUSSED
REALLY WHAT IT IS IS AN
INTERFACE SYSTEM WHERE WE HAVE.
SCO'S LEGACY SYSTEM INTERFACING
WITH THE PASCAL SYSTEM AND
TRANSACTIONS ARE FLYING BACK AND
FORTH AS YOU CAN IMAGINE THAT
HAS CAUSED A LOT MORE NEED FOR
RECONCILIATION.
THERE'S A MUCH HIGHER
RECONCILIATION WORKLOAD BECAUSE
OF THAT.
AND REALLY WERE TRYING TO FORCE
TO SYSTEMS TO TALK TO EACH OTHER
THAT.
SOMETHING OTHER WHATEVER
DESIGNED TO DO SO YOU CAN
UNDERSTAND HOW COMPLEX THAT IS
AS WELL.
SO ALL OF THAT TO SAY IS THAT
WE'RE GETTING THERE AND BUT IT
HAS.
WE HAD HAD BUMPS IN THE ROAD AND
THAT ISN'T SOMETHING THAT WERE
SURPRISED ABOUT TO BE HONEST
WITH YOU BUT WE ARE COMMITTED TO
SEEING THIS THROUGH.
IF YOU LIKE.
TO AT RIGHT MISS BAILEY -- WE
DID PROVIDE A HAND UP FOR YOU
ALL BUT GIVEN THE LARGE AMOUNT
OF GROUND WE'VE COVERED ALREADY
WILL TRY TO KEEP OUR COMMENTS
SHORT -- JUST WANNA NOTE
REGARDING KIND OF THE THE
PROJECT PLAN WE ARE CURRENTLY
WORKING UNDER S. P. R. SEVEN WE
KNOW S. P. R. EIGHT IS -- UNDER
REVIEW AND APPROVAL BY C. T. --
BUT WE WOULD NOTE THAT UNDER S.
PAIR SEVEN JULY TWENTY NINETEEN
WAS ESTABLISHED AS THE END DATE
FOR THE PROJECT AND AS WE NOTED
IN OUR ANALYSIS WE FOUND THAT TO
BE A RATHER ARBITRARY IN DAY FOR
THE PROJECT GIVEN YOU DO HAVE
ALL THESE DEFERRED DEPARTMENTS
THAT ARE.
GONNA BE COMING ON AFTERWARDS AS
WELL AS YOU'RE SEEING NOW BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSALS COMING IN TO
GIVE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
DEPARTMENTS ACTUALLY USE THE
SYSTEM AND SO THEY'RE GOING TO
BE CONTINUING COSTS FOR THIS
PROJECT GOING FORWARD.
WE ALSO WOULDN'T WANT TO GLOSS
OVER THE FACT THAT THE
INTEGRATED SOLUTION IS STILL
UNDER DEVELOPMENT THOUGH THIS
PROJECT IS STILL A HUMAN CHANGE
MANAGEMENT EFFORT.
INTEGRATED SOLUTION IS A
CRITICAL PART OF THE PROJECT AND
THERE ARE STABILIZATION AND
SUPPORT EFFORTS UNDER WAY FOR
THAT TO WORK FOR THINGS THAT
HAVE ALREADY BEEN DEPLOYED AND
THERE IS ADDITIONAL WORK TO DO
FOR THE REMAINING MILESTONES --
WE DO ALSO WANT TO NOTE AGAIN AS
THE DIRECTOR MENTIONED THE
ISSUES AROUND THE MONTH AND YEAR
AND CLOSE OF FINANCIAL
STATEMENTS -- IN SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN THERE ARE AT LEAST
FIFTEEN DEPARTMENTS THAT HAD TO
SUBMIT ESTIMATED STATEMENTS
ACCORDING THE STEERING COMMITTEE
DOCUMENTS IT LOOKS LIKE AT LEAST
FORTY FIVE DEPARTMENTS COULD BE
SUBMITTING ESTIMATES. FOR
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN TO THE EXTENT
THAT THERE ARE CONTINUE
CHALLENGES USING THE SYSTEM THAT
NUMBER COULD GO UP -- AND THOSE
DEPARTMENTS THAT WERE UNABLE TO
CLOSE FOR SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN ARE
CONTINUING TO HAVE -- TROUBLE
FOR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN SO THERE
COULD BE ONGOING RAMIFICATIONS
OF NOT CLOSING THE BOOKS ON TIME --
WE ALSO AGAIN AS WE MENTIONED
CONTINUE TO SEE REQUEST FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDING AND RESOURCES
FOR DEPARTMENTS WE NOTED AT
LEAST.
TWELVE THREE NINETEEN TWENTY
THOSE ARE NOT BEING CATALOGUED
IN ANY CONSISTENT WAY AND ARE
NOT CONSIDERED TO BE PART OF THE
PROJECT COSTS THAT WE WOULD
ANTICIPATE THEM BEING CONTINUING
COSTS.
AS YOU NEED TO AUGMENT RESOURCES
FOR DEPARTMENTS -- AND AGAIN I
THINK WE'RE WE'RE LOOKING FOR TO
ANALYZING AS P. R. EIGHT AND
PROVIDING ANALYSIS TO THE
LEGISLATURE -- BUT AGAIN THOSE
CONCERNS REMAIN FROM S. PAIR.
SEVEN TO S. P. R. EIGHT AS IT'S
BEEN SCOPED.
OUT.
HAS THE PROJECT COMPLETING JULY
OF TWENTY TWENTY I BELIEVE.
BASED ON OUR CONVERSATION ON THE
NUMBER OF DEPARTMENTS THATHAVE
BEEN DEFERRED.
IT DOESN'T ACTUALLY SOUND LIKE
IT'S GOING TO BE.
COMPLETE BY JULY TWENTY TWENTY
SO THE THE PROJECT AS IT IS YOU
KNOW IDENTIFIED IN THE F. S. R.
AND THEN THE SUBSEQUENT S. P.
R.'S.
IDENTIFIED A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
TWO DEPARTMENTS TO BE UTILIZING
THE SYSTEM AND THEN ALL OF THE
FUNCTIONALITY TO BE BUILT.
THAT IS THE FISCAL PROJECT.
SO WHEN THAT IS DONE THAT'S NOT
TO SAY THAT WE WILL NOT CONTINUE
TO HAVE ENHANCEMENT WORK NOR
DOES IT SAY THAT WE WILL NOT BE
IN A POSITION TO HAVE TO ON
BOARD DEPARTMENTS.
AT A LATER DATE WHAT I DID YOU
KNOW INDICATE WAS IT SURELY I
WOULD NEED -- YOU KNOW BE SEE
PEOPLE FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
BRING ON SOME OF THESE LARGER --
DEFERRED DEPARTMENTS WHAT MAY
ALSO HAPPEN IS DEPENDING ON WHAT
THAT GAP ANALYSIS SHOWS.
IF I NEED TO DO ADDITIONAL
FUNCTIONALITY OR CHANGE THE
SYSTEM IN ANY SIGNIFICANT WAY
BUT I WOULD ALSO AT THAT POINT
TRIGGER ANOTHER -- PROJECT AND
SO WE WOULD HAVE.
THE PROJECT TO IMPLEMENT YOU
KNOW EITHER.
CDC ARE CALTRANS AND AND THAT
WOULD BE TRACKED AND AND HAVE
OVERSIGHT.
ON ITS OWN AS A PROJECT OKAY SO
YOU'RE SAYING THERE COULD BE A
FIFTY CAL PHASE TWO OR PHASE
CALIPHATES THREE AS IT WERE.
AND THE MONEY THAT IS CURRENTLY
IN THE BUDGET BELL I THINK IT'S
MEN LIKE SIXTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS OVER THE COURSE OF THE
NEXT THREE YEARS [inaudible]
THAT.
DOES NOT COVERED THE ON BOARDING
OF THAT ANY OF THESE DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS OR ANY THE PROJECT
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH THAT.
CORRECT WE'RE NOT INCLUDE WELL
THESE AND WE BELIEVE WE'RE GONNA
BE ABLE TO BRING ON CD T. WITHIN
EXISTING RESOURCES BECAUSE IT IS
SUCH A SMALL DEPARTMENT.
I'M IN.
TWENTY TWENTY ARE AND THEY DON'T
REQUIRE ADDITIONAL FUNCTIONALITY
THAT'S A KEY PIECES THAT HAVE
IT'S THEY'RE GOING TO COME ON
UTILIZING WHAT WE HAVE.
STEFAN I JUST TO FOLLOW UP ON
WITH THE CHAIR ASKED INTO WOULD
YOU ANTICIPATE WITH S. P. R. A.
THAT'S FINISHING -- THE FINAL
COMPONENTS OF THE ONE UNDER THE
FOR AGENCIES THEN DO YOU
ANTICIPATE LIKE AS P. R. NINE
FOR ALL THE OTHER ONES I
EXPECTED NEW PROJECT.
SO YOU CAN PLAY THE NEW PRODUCT
COMPLETELY NEW PROJECT SO IT
WOULD BE ABOVE THE SCOPE THAT WE
ORIGINALLY SET OUT TO DO WE ARE
NOW.
AT IT WOULD BE A PROJECT TO
BRING ON CALTRANS AND WHATEVER
ADDITIONAL MODULES THEY MAY NEED.
AND I LIKE I WOULD JUST ADD THAT
WE WOULD BRING THAT PROJECT TO
THE LEGISLATURE FOR APPROVAL
SURELY WOULDN'T JUST DO THAT.
YOU KNOW I'M JUST THINKING OUT
LOUD IN TERMS OF AND AND IN IN.
IN JUST FOLLOWING UP WITH THE
WITH THE LEAD LINE ARRAYS --
LINE OF QUESTIONING BY THE CHAIR
IS THAT IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE
ALLOWING A LOT OF THESE -- THAT
YOU FOLKS WOULD INTO
INSTITUTIONAL KNOWLEDGE TO TO
LEAVE I GUESS AGAIN OF JUST
BRING THEM BACK AND WHEN WE JUST.
CONTINUE TO UTILIZE THEM OVER --
SO I'M TO TO WORK OUT WE HAVE --
DIFFERENT AGENCIES RIGHT SO WE
HAVE BEEN HAD A CONTRACT WITH
OUR SYSTEM INTEGRATOR IN PLACE
SENSE SINCE.
TWENTY TWELVE AND UNDER THE YOU
KNOW ACQUISITION -- OR THE
PROCUREMENT RULES OF THE STATE
WE WOULD WANT TO GO OUT TO LOOK
FOR A COMPETITIVE BID SO BY
CONTINUALLY EXTENDING THE
PROJECT.
BY NECESSITY WE HAVE BEEN
EXTENDING THE CONTRACT WITH WITH
OUR SYSTEM INTEGRATOR INTO THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT AGAIN.
WE MAY.
YOU DON'T BRING THEM BACK IS YOU
KNOW DOWN THE ROAD IN AND SAY IT
YOU ARE THE MOST QUALIFIED AND
AND YOU KNOW IT'S IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE STATE TO BRING
YOU BACK EITHER PRICE PLANER.
OR WHAT THEY CAN BRING BUT UNTIL
WE PUT IT OUT -- INTO THE
COMPETITIVE TO THE NEW BID FOR
THE THERE WOULD BE A NEW AND
EXCITING THANK YOU.
AND THEN AT MISTER THE JHANA
FROM CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE WOULD LOVE.
TO GET YOUR YOUR TAKE ON ON THE
CURRENT STATUS OF THE PROJECT
GOOD MORNING I JUST WANT TO
STATE THAT DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY -- JUST SPEAKER
COOKIE TO ASPIRATE SO WHEN.
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY AND
FISCAL GOT TOGETHER AND
DETERMINED THAT THE SCOPE AND
SCHEDULE NEEDED TO PREPAY THREE
BASS LINE.
WE BEGAN WORKING WITH THEM ON
THE DIFFERENT ITEMS THAT WE'VE
LAID OUT THAT NEEDED TO BE.
REMEDIATED.
N. FISCALE AT THAT TIME ACTUALLY
STARTED ON THAT REMEDIATION
RIGHT AWAY IT WASN'T AS IF THEY
JUST SAT BACK AND STARTED
DRAWING OF THAT DOCUMENTS.
LIKE THE DIRECTORS SPOKE TO
THEIR TICKETS FOR UP TO ABOUT
THREE THOUSAND AT THREE MONTHS
AGO AND THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO
BRING THAT DOWN TO TWO THOUSAND
AND THE TREND SEEMS TO KEEP
GOING THAT WAY -- IN PART OF
THAT IS LOOKING FOR TRENDS ON
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE THAT IF
THEY IF THEY WERE DEFECTS
CONFIGURATION ISSUES ARE JUST I
DON'T KNOW HOW TO USE THE SYSTEM
AND I NEED SOME HELP -- THAT.
THE MOVING OF DEPARTMENT CAL
STARS DEPARTMENTS OFFER CAL
STARS AN ITEM THAT WE BROUGHT UP --
IN.
THE PROJECT GOT ON THAT IN
ACTION LIKE THE DARK SO I THINK
THERE'S ONLY FOUR LEFT AND WE
ANTICIPATE THAT THAT WILL BE
DONE BY AT LEAST JULY OF THIS
YEAR -- SO JUST GOING OVER THE
SB ARE REAL QUICK SO THEY ARE
REDUCING SOME OF THE THE SCOPE
THAT IS IDENTIFIED AS NOT
CRITICAL FOR THEIR MINIMUM
MINIMUM MINIMUM VIABLE PRODUCT.
SO THE AN INTEGRATED SOLUTION TO
WORK SO THEY'RE JUST LOOKING AT
THAT THAT FUNCTIONALITY NEEDS
NEEDS TO BE IN PLACE -- THE
REMAINING SCOPE AS MENTIONED
WILL BE DONE IN  MINNOW OR IF
IT REQUIRES OF THE PROJECT THAT
WILL BE BROUGHT FORWARD IN GO
THROUGH THAT THE APPROVAL
PROCESS.
THEY'VE EXTENDED THIS GET ABOUT
ONE YEAR -- AGAIN THAT MINIMUM
VIABLE PRODUCT SHOULD BE DONE BY
JULY TWENTY TWENTY AND THEY'VE
ALSO EXTENDED THE PRODUCTION
SUPPORT FROM ACCENTURE SO.
THE SI WILL BE THERE TO HELP
WITH PRODUCTION SUPPORT AND THE
EXCEPT THE SYSTEM EXPECTANT OF
THIS THE X..
SYSTEM ACCEPTANCE IS EXPECTED TO
BE BACK IN -- TWENTY TWENTY TWO
RESOURCES.
FROM THE STATE SIDE THE SEEM TO
REMAIN THE SAME THEY'VE ADDED
SOME CONTRACT -- MONIES -- IN
ONE OF THE THINGS THEY'VE ALSO
DONE IS THEY'VE CREATED SOME
DEDICATED TEAMS TO WORK ON
SPECIFICALLY THE DEVELOPMENT.
BEFORE THEY HAD TEAM A TEAM THAT
WERE SPLIT SO IF THEY HAD ISSUES
IN THE PRODUCTION AREA THIS TEAM
MEMBERS WOULD SPLIT OFF FROM THE
PRODUCTION AND GO WORK ON
PRODUCTION.
NOW THEY HAVE A TEAM DEDICATED
FOR PRODUCTION AND THE TEAM
DEDICATED FOR THE ABOUT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF OF THE SYSTEM SO
ISSUE UP.
THE SYSTEM FUNCTIONALITY -- SO
ALL IN ALL WORKING CLOSELY WITH
THEM ON THE APPROVALS WE EXPECT
THAT TO BE DONE SOMETIME THIS
WEEK HOWEVER THERE ARE STILL
SOME CONTRACT NEGOTIATIONS GOING
ON WHICH ONCE WE GET THE FINAL
DOLLARS THAT WOULD BE ADDED TO
THE S. P. R. AND THAT.
WE SEE NO PROBLEMS WITH THAT --
APPROVAL GOING TO QUICKLY.
OKAY THANK YOU SO.
SAID MARCH TWENTY NINETEEN WHEN
YOU DID YOUR LATEST PROJECT
OVERSIGHT REPORT IN THE CONTEXT
OF A TARGET.
DELIVERY DATE OF JULY FIRST.
TWENTY NINETEEN THE PROJECT WAS
READ AND WAS NOT ON TRACK TO
SATISFIED CUSTOMERS BUSINESS
OBJECTIVES CHIEF OBJECTIVES AND
IMPROVE TIME FRAME.
OUR OBJECTIVES WITHIN APPROVED
BUDGET.
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS THAT WE'VE
RESCRIPT THE PROJECT TO ME BASS
LINE TO TO SUCH AN EXTENT THAT?
THE NEW PROJECT WOULD NOT BE IN
THE RED STATUS CORRECT A CONTENT
AND BEING IN THE RED DOES THAT
MEAN FAILURE MEANS ARE AT MEANS
ITEMS NEED TO BE CORRECTED.
AND AND THEY'VE DONE THAT
THROUGH THE S. P. R. PROCESS AND
TO THE ACTIONS THEY'VE TAKEN
SINCE JANUARY TO THIS DAY.
AND THEN I'VE GOT SOME QUESTIONS
ABOUT SOME OF THE CHALLENGES YOU
LAID OUT WITH WITH A MILE
STERN'S -- SO THE FIRST
MILESTONE MORE MILES AND TO I
GUESS STATEWIDE DEPOSITS
FUNCTIONALITY WHICH WAS DEPLOYED
IN OCTOBER TWENTY EIGHTEEN IS
THAT STILL EXPERIENCING
STABILIZATION ISSUES -- IS UP
AND RESOLVED.
SAID THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT --
TO AND I DON'T KNOW.
THAT.
TO THE MISTER LOIS HADN'T HAD
MADE REFERENCE TO AS WELL AND
AND I HAD ALLUDED TO IS THAT
WHEN WE BROUGHT ON SOME OF THOSE
FUNCTIONALITIES WE INCREASED THE
WORKLOAD.
AT AT HOME AT HOME WE CALL WOMEN
WHEN THEY'RE IN THE THE THE FOUR
PARTNERS AGENCIES BACKGROUND --
INTO SOME OF THOSE WE HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO ADDRESS -- I THAT THE
STABILIZATION WITH -- BESIDES.
BESIDES THE THAT INTEGRATION I
DON'T THINK THAT THERE IS
ANYTHING LEFT ON ON MILESTONE TO
WHITE AND I CAN GIVE YOU A
SPECIFIC ITEM THAT THAT WAS DONE
SO WHAT THE PROJECT IT IS THEY
STREAMLINED THEIR BATCH
PROCESSES.
AND PARTLY THEY ACTUALLY BROKEN
UP INTO SMALLER PIECES SO THAT
WAS MORE EASILY TO HANDLE SO.
IF YOU HAD A HUGE BATCH PROCESS
THAT WAS RUNNING AND YOU HAD A
PROBLEM SAY THREE QUARTERS OF
THE WAY FACT IT WOULD CAUSE
MAJOR PROBLEMS FOR THE BROKEN UP
INTO SMALLER CHUNKS OF THAT.
I'D BE MUCH MORE EFFICIENT.
AT AND THEN THE RELEASE ONE INTO
WHICH IS DEPLOYED IN DECEMBER.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN IS THAT STILL
EXPERIENCING CIVILIZATION ISSUES
ARE HAVE THOSE BEEN RESOLVED
ACTUALLY THOSE ARE RELATED TO
MILESTONE TWO AND THREE THOSE
ARE ALSO OKAY THOSE ARE RELATED
[inaudible] FIVE AND THEN THE
MOUSE AND FOUR AND FIVE WERE THE
ONES THAT WERE RE BASS LINES.
AND HE'S GOT A I GOT.
SO WITH THAT I THINK PERHAPS WE
WILL TRANSITION.
TO A PANEL TO WHICH IS IN STATE
ACCOUNT TEAM AND OVERSIGHT.
AND A HAVE AND STILL HAND.
AS PART OF FINANCING WITH US MR
LOW LAST -- FROM THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE THANK YOU
AND YOUR AND THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE.
I AND THEN WE'LL ADD LARRY
SATCHER FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AS WELL.
SO I GUESS THE MILLION DOLLAR
QUESTION -- IN THIS CASE THE TWO
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLAR QUESTION
IS OF COURSE ENSURING THAT THAT
THE SYSTEM CAN ACCURATELY --
SPORT AVERAGE AT USE THE STATE'S
FINANCIAL KEY FINANCIAL REPORTS
AND THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE AS ALLUDED TO SOME OF
THAT THE CONSIDERATIONS AND
CONCERNS.
WOULD JUST LOVE TO GET I THINK
EITHER YOUR UPDATE ON WHAT'S
BEEN DONE TO ADDRESS THOSE
CONCERNS AT OUR LEVEL OF
CONFIDENCE THAT.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD WE WILL BE
ABLE TO ACCURATELY PRODUCE THE
CALF ANOTHER.
OTHER KEY REPORTS SURE ALL UP
KICK IT OFF HERE AND AND LET MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE PANEL JUMPED
IN AS THEY SEE FIT BUT BUT WHAT.
THIS WHOLE.
RE BASELINE IN THE PROJECT WAS --
WAS AN EFFORT IS PART OF CHANGE
MANAGEMENT ALSO IS MAKING SURE
THAT THAT'S THE CONTROLLERS IN A
POSITION TO BE SUCCESSFUL WHEN A
CUT OVER AND SO.
THAT THAT'S THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
DOING -- MAKE SURE THEY HAVE THE
TIME TO TEST THE PIECES THEY
NEED TO TEST THAT THE
FUNCTIONALITIES THERE -- WITH
RESPECT TO THE CATHARINE OTHER
PIECES AND AND SO THAT'S WHAT WE
THOUGHT WOULD PROPOSE A
THOUGHTFUL APPROACH WE'RE GONNA
WE'RE GONNA SPEND THIS NEXT YEAR
GETTING THEM READY.
TO CUT OVER -- AND THEN WE'RE
GONNA RUN THEIR SYSTEM PARALLEL.
SO THEY CAN.
DO THAT SECOND THAT NEXT
CATHERINE AND HAVE AND HAVE THE
CONFIDENCE THAT THAT WHAT'S BEEN
WITHOUT ONE SYSTEM TYPES WHAT'S
PRODUCED A LEGACY SYSTEM.
AND AT THAT POINT WE CAN SHUT IT
DOWN BUT I FEEL LIKE WE'RE IN A
GOOD PLACE -- WE'VE LEARNED A
LOT AND AND AND WITH THE HELP OF
THE LEGISLATURE AS I SAID WE'RE
WE'RE GET WEIRD BEEN DEPLOYING
OUR RESOURCES MORE TARGETED TO
HELP THOSE DEPARTMENTS WERE TO
GET THE BEST VALUE -- AND WITH
THE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES THAT
THE LEGISLATURE.
WAS NOT GOOD ENOUGH TO HELP US
WITH IN THE SPRING -- WHEN THOSE
COME ON BOARD UNTIL I WE'RE
GOING TO DO THE SAME SO?
AND THAT SOMETHING ELSE YOU
WANNA TOWARD.
YEAH THIRTY SETTER WITH FINANCE
AND I'LL JUST ADD THAT -- WE'VE
BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
PROJECT ON PROVIDING THAT
ADDITIONAL TRAINING TO THE
DEPARTMENTS TO HELP THEM GET
CURRENT IN CLOSING WE THINK THAT
THAT'LL BE A SUCCESS FACTOR WHEN
IT'S TIME TO PRODUCE THE KAFIRS
MAKING SURE THAT DEPARTMENTS ARE
CLOSING IN A TIMELY MANNER.
SO INVESTING A LOT OF TIME AND
EFFORT INTO THEM.
WHAT I WANT TO ADD IS THAT?
ONCE WE'RE DONE I HAVE NO DOUBT
THAT THIS WILL WORK.
I THINK ONCE WE'RE DONE IT WILL
WORK -- IT'S WORKED AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL IT'S WORKED IN
OTHER STATES.
EVEN THE WERE MUCH MORE
COMPLICATED THAN ALL OF THOSE I
THINK IT WILL WORK.
WE'RE JUST GONNA HAVE TO MAKE
SURE AS MISTER GILL AND SAID
THAT WE MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
THE RESOURCES WE NEED THE
TRAINING THAT WE NEED AND
EVERYTHING EVERYTHING ELSE THAT
WE NEED TO MAKE IT HAPPEN. ONE
OTHER THING THAT'S GOING TO
CHANGE MISTER SATURN I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS TOGETHER IS THE
WAY WE DO ACCOUNTING POLICY --
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FINANCE
HAS THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
PROVIDING ACCOUNTING POLICIES OF
THE DEPARTMENTS WELL THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE HAS THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO PROVIDE
REPORTING POLICY.
IN ORDER TO PRODUCE THE
BUDGETARY LEGAL REPORT AND THE
KAFFIR.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO WORK
TOGETHER ON ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
EQUATION -- AS WE MOVE FORWARD
AND YOU SYSTEM BECAUSE NOW WE'RE
ALL GOING TO BE IN ONE SYSTEM
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE USING
DIFFERENT SYSTEMS.
AND ASKING DEPARTMENTS TO DO
DIFFERENT THINGS SO IN THAT
RESPECT WE HAVE STARTED WORKING
TOGETHER WE WORK VERY CLOSELY IN
MAKING SURE THAT WHATEVER
POLICIES DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ISSUES THE DEPARTMENTS ARE
THINGS THAT.
WE CAN LIVE WITH AND THAT WILL
WORK FOR US AS WELL.
AND WE'RE DOING THE SAME ONE WE
HAVE REPORTING POLICIES AND
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT WE NEED
FROM DEPARTMENTS ARE TO PRODUCE
THE FINANCIALS.
THAT IT WORKS FOR THE DEPARTMENT
AND WORKS WITH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AS WELL SO AGAIN IT'S
GONNA REQUIRE MORE COLLABORATION
WE HAVE STARTED THAT. TO TAKE
THEM BACK TO A QUESTION I HAD
ASKED EARLIER IN THE WEEK BE
TABLED FOR THAT SO.
ARE THERE ENTITIES THAT ARE
REPORTING CONCERNS WITH USING
FISCALE.
I BECAUSE OF THEIR CONCERN ABOUT.
SYSTEM ACCURACY IN MEETING
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS.
AS OF RIGHT NOW THE ONLY
DEPARTMENT THAT I'M AWARE OF
THAT HAS RAISE THAT CONCERN IN
IN MAY AND MAY STILL BE A LITTLE
BIT CURRENT HIS PARCEL SERVICES
THEY ARE ONE OF THE DEPARTMENTS
USING CAL STARS.
AND THEY WANTED TO USE THAT IN
PART TO HELP THEM VALIDATE THE
FEDERAL REPORTS THAT ARE GOING
TO BE PRODUCED OUT OF FISCAL --
I HAVEN'T RECEIVED ANY
INDICATION FROM THEM THAT THEY
WILL NOT MEET THEIR NEEDS BUT IT
WAS SOMETHING THAT THEY IT WAS A
TOOL THAT THEY WANTED TO USE TO
HELP THEM ENSURE.
THAT THEY COULD CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE THAT FED THE FEDERAL
REPORTING.
OKAY SO THEY'RE KIND OF RUNNING
TO DO ALL APPROACH THAT AT THE
MOMENT.
THAT'S CORRECT.
I'M AND THEN.
AGAIN BACK TO THE QUESTION OF
SORT OF LEVEL OF DETAIL.
THAT -- THAT THIS GAL THE SYSTEM
IS CAPABLE OF SO I THINK THE
DIRECTORIES AS THE EXAMPLE OF OF
APPLE APPLES RIGHT SO IF YOU'RE
CLASSIFYING SAVVY CAN.
NEW START WITH FOOD AND FRUIT
AND VEGETABLES APPLES YOU HAVE
GALA APPLES OR YOU CAN EXPRESS.
HOW?
LIKE WE HAVE TO HAVE A AN
APPROACH TO SELECTING WHAT LEVEL
OF GRANULARITY WE WANT AND MAKE
SURE THAT ALL DEPARTMENTS ARE
THAN USING THAT SAME LEVEL OF
GRANULARITY.
THAT ACTUALLY STRIKES ME AS
QUITE A MASSIVE.
UNDERTAKING WHAT IS OUR APPROACH
TO THAT RIGHT NOW AND AND HOW
ARE WE INSURING THAT SAM.
THE DEPARTMENTS ARE GOING TO BE
OPERATING IN UNIFORM FASHION.
WELL I'LL TAKE A FIRST CUT AT IT --
OUR APPROACH WAS THAT TO BE
HONEST WITH YOU THAT.
WE GOT CAUGHT OFF GUARD -- BUT
BY THE LEVEL OF DETAIL IN ON THE
PROCUREMENT SIDE AND THE THE
WORKLOAD THAT THEY PUT ON A
DEPARTMENTS AND SO AS A STEERING
COMMITTEE AS IS CONTROL AGENCIES
WE CAME TOGETHER SO WHAT WE DO
ABOUT THIS AND SO WE BACK
CUSTOMERS REQUIREMENTS IN THE
SHORT TERM.
SO WE DIDN'T CRUSH THE STATE'S
BECOME A PROCESS -- WELL WE'RE
WORKING TOGETHER TO D. G. S. AND
CONTROLLER IN PARTICULAR BUT
WHAT WE'RE INVOLVED THE IT'S
IT'S IT'S IT'S NOT A PROJECT
ISSUE PER SE IT'S MORE OF A
POLICY CALL -- BUT WE'RE WORKING
TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE WE FIND
WHAT WHAT IS BUT WE DO WE THINK
THAT RIGHT LEVEL DETAIL IS AN
AND ONCE WEEK SORT OF LAND THAT
WE WILL ENGAGE WITH THE
LEGISLATURE -- BECAUSE YOU HAVE
SOME EXPECTATIONS OF OF
TRANSPARENCY OUT OF THE SYSTEM
AND AND WE'RE SHOWCASING SOME OF
THAT IN A PILOT RIGHT NOW OF ON
THE PROCUREMENT SIDE LIKE.
WHAT DEPARTMENTS PURCHASE AT A
VERY GRANULAR LEVEL DETAIL -- SO
IN THAT CONTEXT WE WOULD WE
WOULD COME BACK AND HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT.
YOU KNOW WHAT THE LEGISLATURE
THINKS IS RIGHT LEVEL DETAIL BUT
YOU KNOW WE WE DON'T THANK LEAST
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE WE DON'T
THINK IT THESE IN THE APPLE
ANALOGY THAT'S THAT'S BEEN USED
FAR TOO OFTEN BUT BUT BUT WE
DON'T THINK IT MATTERS IF IT'S A
GREEN APPLE OR FOOD.
THE APPLE OR MACINTOSH APPLE OR
OR BRAEBURN YOU KNOW THAT --
IT'S WHAT WHAT WHAT THAT WHAT
WHAT FOOD WE BUYING FOR OUR
TWENTY FOUR HOUR CARE FACILITIES
OUR PRISONS AND HOW MUCH WE'RE
PAYING FOR IT WHERE WE SOURCING
IT AND WE GETTING THE BEST VALUE
FOR THE STATEMENT THAT'S THAT'S
A SORT INFORMATION THAT WE NEED
TO NOW -- IS AN ADMINISTRATION
THAT THE LEGISLATURE I WOULD
ASSUME WANTS TO KNOW FROM AN
OVERSIGHT PERSPECTIVE ON AND AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING WE'RE
TRYING TO THREAD THAT NEEDLE IF
YOU WILL RIGHT AND THEN IT'S
JUST ENSURING THAT THAN THE
BUSINESS ROLES ARE.
THE SENATE WILL ENSURE THE
BUSINESS RULES THAT THEY WON'T
BE ABLE TO SAY WHAT AND THAT'S
THAT'S THAT'S WHY IT BECAME AN
ISSUE ON THE FRONT END AND HAVE.
THE RIGHT.
AND ON THE BACK AND IT'S ALSO
GOING TO FOLLOW IN OUR CLAREMONT
IT'S FOLKS WHEN THEY'RE
APPROVING THE VOUCHERS FOR
PAYMENT THEY'RE GONNA WANT TO
SEE THE DETAILS.
AS WELL SO THE SYSTEM GONNA
REQUIRED THEN THEY'RE GONNA
MIGHT BE SURE THAT IT'S IN THE
VOUCHER INFORMATION BEFORE THEY
ACTUALLY ALLOW THAT WARRANT TO
BE ISSUED.
AB AND I THINK ONE LAST QUESTION
FOR ME ON THIS ON ON THIS TOPIC
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
MENTIONED THAT THERE FORTY FIVE
DEPARTMENTS -- THE REASON
ESTIMATES FOR CLOSING I BELIEVE
IS THE NUMBER.
DOES THAT GIVE YOU PAUSE OR A
CAUSE FOR CONCERN.
SO AS AN ACCOUNTANT I CAN NEVER
SAY THAT THAT ONE GIVE ME CAUSE
FOR CONCERN BUT ESTIMATES
ANOTHER NEW THINGS WE'VE HAD
DEPARTMENTS DOING ESTIMATES IN
THEIR OLD LEGACY SYSTEMS FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS AS WELL --
NOT AS MANY GRANTED BUT IT HAS
HAPPENED IT'S NOT A NEW THING.
UP THE DEPARTMENT ARE GOING TO
DO ESTIMATES THIS YEAR ARE NOT
MATERIAL.
FROM MY POINT OF VIEW NOW
WHETHER THE STATE AUDITOR AGREES
WITH THAT STATEMENT.
IT'S GOING TO BE THEIR CALL.
I THINK WE'LL BE FINE BUT HAVING
ESTIMATES IS NOT NECESSARILY A
BAD THING AS LONG AS THEY CAN
DEFEND THOSE ESTIMATES AND WHEN
THE AUDITOR WALKS INTO THEIR
OFFICE TO SAY HEY.
YOU GUYS PROVIDED ESTIMATES HOW
DID YOU COME UP WITH THAT SHOW
ME HOW YOU CAME UP WITH IT.
AND SEE IF THEY'RE SATISFIED IF
THEY CAN SATISFY THE AUDITOR.
WILL BE FINE -- BUT AGAIN
ESTIMATES ARE NOT A NEW THING
HOPEFULLY THEY'LL BE MINIMAL AND
HOPEFULLY AS WE MOVE FORWARD
WILL HAVE LESS AND LESS AND
HOPEFULLY AT SOME POINT.
NINE AND I JUST LIKE TO ADD THAT --
ONE OF THE EFFORTS BROKE THAT
ARE CURRENTLY UNDER WAY IS TO
WORK CLOSELY WITH THE CONTROLLER
AND THE STATE AUDITOR. TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL GUIDELINES TO
DEPARTMENTS WHO HAVE TO DO
ESTIMATES TO ENSURE THAT THEY'RE
DONE.
ACCURATELY ACCURACY IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING IN REGARDS TO
THOSE ESTIMATES -- EVERY
DEPARTMENT USES ESTIMATES FOR
YOUR AND REPORTING PURPOSES THE
DIFFERENCE WITH THE DEPARTMENTS
ARE A LITTLE BIT BEHIND OF
FISCALES ARE AT A DIFFERENT
STARTING POINT.
SO WHICH COULD HELP THEM KIND OF
DEFECTIVE DEVELOP THAT PROCESS
AND ENSURE THAT IT'S ACCURATE.
ANYTHING ELSE THAT YOU WOULD ADD.
JUST IN TERMS OF OF OVERSIGHT.
I IN THE CONTEXT OF A SCALE.
NO I WOULD I WOULD SAY -- YOU
KNOW WHAT WE APPRECIATE THE
ENGAGEMENT STAFF -- YOUR STAFF
REACH OUT TO US OFTEN -- AND AND
HAVE ONGOING DIALOGUE ABOUT THIS
PROJECT WE APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATURE SUPPORT.
THE MOVE WE'VE BEEN HERE A
COUPLE OF TIMES YOU KNOW HADN'T
HAND ASKING FOR ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES BRING US AND CROSS THE
FINISH LINE AND AND LET SUCH AS
BEEN EVERY TIME SO WE THANK YOU
FOR THAT AND WE LOOK FORWARD.
TO TO THE COMING BACK NEXT CHEN
TUNG WHERE WE ARE AND HAVING
THEM CONTINUOUS PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATION.
WELL THANK YOU AND THANK YOU AND
ALL OF OUR PANELISTS AND HAVE
JOIN US TWENTIES TODAY AND AND
TAKING TIME TO UPDATE THE
COMMITTEE.
COMMITTEES ON ON THE PROJECT
STATUS.
I THINK I'M FROM MY PERSPECTIVE.
THINK LIKE WE SAID THIS IS HAS
BEEN A TRULY MASSIVE UNDERTAKING
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- I
THINK A LOT HAS BEEN
ACCOMPLISHED WE'VE CERTAINLY.
SOUNDS LIKE WE HAVE A A FAIR
WAYS TO GO WHEN YOU THINK OF
THAT IN THE CONTEXT OF OF THE
THE SUBSEQUENT FACE SAYS.
AND I WAS STRUCK IN YOUR
TESTIMONY I THINK BY THE NUMBER
OF LESSONS.
THE REASONS THAT WE'VE LEARNED
OVER THE LAST FIFTEEN YEARS.
AND MUCH WITH THE PROCESS IS TO
ENSURE THAT WE DON'T MAKE THE
SAME MISTAKES ON UP TO KEEP
RELEARNING THOSE LESSONS RIGHT
BECAUSE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WE'RE GOING.
TO KEEP ON TAKING ON GIGANTIC.
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY AND OTHER
LARGE SCALE PROJECTS AND I THINK
SOME OF THE THINGS YOU
HIGHLIGHTED AROUND.
FACT THAT YEAH IT'S NEVER JUST A
TECHNOLOGY PROJECT IT'S A IT'S A
HUGE CHANGE MANAGEMENT PROJECT.
THAT IS SO IMPORTANT -- SOME OF
THE THINGS YOU TALKED ABOUT.
IN TERMS OF THE ROLL OUT AS AND
VERY DIFFUSE PROJECT ACROSS MANY
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS AND SEEN
THE SPIKY NESS.
OF SIX ASSN FOR YOU'RE NOT A
RIGHT ACTUALLY IF WE CAN ADOPT
THIS IS A BEST PRACTICE.
THEN WE CAN ENSURE THAT EVERYONE.
IS HAVING A SUCCESSFUL ROLLOUT
SO.
I'M THE ONE THING THAT I THINK
WOULD BE REALLY VERY VALUABLE IS
PARTICULARLY AS WE HAVE THEY HI
THE TECHNOLOGY INNOVATION GROUP
THAT'S GONNA BE STARTING UP IS
TO ENSURE THAT.
AS THIS PROJECT WINDS DOWN THAT
THERE'S A REALLY THOROUGH KIND
OF DEBRIEF AND AND REFLECTION SO
THAT WE WE CAN TAKE EVERYTHING
THAT.
AT THAT WE'VE LEARNED THROUGHOUT
THIS JOURNEY AND DIED AND APPLY
IT TO FUTURE PROJECTS -- LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU ALL
IS TO MOVE THIS FORWARD TO
ENSURE THAT THE CONTINUED
SUCCESS OF A OF THE PROJECT
IMPLEMENTATION.
AND LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING AND
UPDATES -- AN UPDATE ON PROJECT
STATUS AS WELL.
WITH THAT I THINK WE ARE
ADJOURNED [inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
QUESTION.
COME ONE RIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME
AND NINETY EIGHT THANK YOU SO